e
and seeing the time looks like it is
9:00 according to our clock on the wall
here um I will open the
pledge rep Smith would you lead
us iedge Al to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which stands one
all okay I thank everyone and um welcome
to a new term in fish and game I hope
that all the members uh are going to
enjoy this and learn a lot uh I hope
everybody got the welcome letter that I
did send out to all of the uh committee
members and if you haven't gotten your
contact information to the clerk um
please uh go ahead and and uh get that
to her as soon as possible with that I
think what we should do is probably uh
start with some introductions uh
basically um we'll start and go around
the room and you can say who you are
where you are from or where you
represent and um anything that you find
pertinent to why you chose to serve on
this committee or uh interests or
anything like that um and uh just to
be
distri
uh I'm your chairman again for a second
uh term in a row uh representative James
Spain from uh Deerfield Candia and
Auburn District Rockingham 2 I live in
Deerfield and um I have been in the
house for six terms now and always
served here on Fish and Game um Avid
Hunter uh don't fish much because I am
not good at it
um
guide you know we got to be honest about
what we're we have shortcomings in so um
that's
that representative Mike wette uh from
colbrook representing Coos District 3 uh
I my second term I uh wanted to be on
the fish game and Marine Resources
committee because of uh being in the
North Country so much of our economy and
our lifestyle has to do with the
outdoors and it's very important to uh
keep it friendly and welcoming to the
whole state of New Hampshire uh I uh
don't hunt anymore uh I do fish and I
Motorsports good morning everybody uh
this is representative Abul Khan
represent C Brook the Bingham District
30 uh this is my uh sixth term fourth
term in this committee and I am a
recreational fisherman recreational
all good morning my name is
representative Katherine Harvey I
represent chesher 6 which is
Chesterfield Hinsdale and Westmorland I
am none of the above um I'm here for my
fifth term because because um I use the
outdoors in a different way my husband
and I are Avid campers we kayak we hike
um and I would like our Outdoors to stay
grandchildren representative tutor
Rockingham 1 Northwood notingham um I
own a rather large chunk of land that's
in current use regulation so I have a
lot of hunters on it I don't do too many
too much hunting anymore more though my
children were born with rifles in their
hands um but that's the main reason I
gay morning Mr chair I'm Peter LoveIt
this is uh my second term in the house
I've moved over from resources
Recreation and development um they're a
little bit busier over there I'm still a
full-time Pastor in Meredith New
Hampshire so this is I'm looking forward
to this for several reasons all of these
interests appeal to me um I also have a
friend from an old church that I served
whose son was just commissioned as a
fish and game officer so I'm looking
forward to learning more about this
committee and and its reach into the
state in the mountains in the lakes
oceans
Etc good morning my name is Wayne
Pearson I am from straford County
District 12 summersworth in Rollinsford
I am an avid hiker and outdoor
photographer
good morning everyone I'm Shan Durkin
I'm from Kaz one which represents Dalton
Lancaster North umberland and Stratford
I'm an Aver Outdoorsman I been hunting
big bow hunter um like Mr olette said
that uh North Country is a great place
um hoping that uh we can preserve it
that's
it good morning my name is Terry oor and
I'm um cheser district 7 in Kean and I
hunters okay with that uh at least now
everybody out there uh from the
department and the commission and such
have an idea of who we are and I will
ask someone to close the door so we have
a little bit more quiet in here and uh
go ahead and open this up to the
orientation section of the uh program
and um I've been requested by the
director to let the employees of the
department go first so that they can get
back to their jobs so with all uh due
don't forget to turn the mic on y got
that that was so my name is dearer
Grimes um I worked in the private sector
for 15 years as an HR Director uh joined
fishing game in July of
2022 and let me tell you state is
definitely different than private sector
um but as ask any employee what an HR
department is and you'll get an answer
that Prim primarily deals with the most
uncomfortable aspects of work HR
violations layoffs and firing but the
truth is human resources is there to
support employees it's quite literally
literally a resource for humans um in
our department we do payroll recruit
candidates um hire the right candidates
for fishing game update policies conduct
disciplinary actions maintain employee
records um conduct benefit analysis the
human resource department heavily
contributes to the company's
culture if HR generally cares about the
well-being of employees the culture will
be one of the openness and growth I care
a great deal about being a fishing game
I'm very proud to be part of fishing
game
um that's all I have thank you again for
having us here today does anybody on the
committee have any questions
representative Harvey um I've never
heard of the HR department updating
policies do you write policies too we do
write policies yes I thought that came
from like a policy committee we've got
well we're we're a smaller agency so we
actually work with the division of
personnel on policies okay thank
you any other questions representative
love
it thank you um how many roughly how
many people are you overseeing how many
in fishing game there's about 20 25
right now thank you
thanks any other
questions seeing none thank you so much
thank
up hit the button and the like there we
go okay thank you for having us today my
name is Nicola Whitley I'm the chair of
the public affairs division at fishing
game we are 16 full-time and one
part-time employee and hundreds of
volunteers who help us do our
programming we're divided in sort of in
half the education unit and the um
information unit I'll describe those for
you our education programs include
aquatic resources education which under
which is our let's go fishing program so
representative Spain if you'd like us to
help you with your
fishing um we also have the Watershed
education program which works with
schools and water study ecology
Institute uh obviously Hunter and
Trapper education you've probably all
heard of that and um that unit is
responsible for our albrook hunter
Education Center in holderness New
Hampshire we have our becoming Outdoors
woman program which uh aims to get women
more comfortable in outdoor activities
conservation education unit which is um
pro project wild uh which is teacher
based so train the trainer model for
teachers for to reach out to students we
have our Wildlife stewards program which
are um speakers who go around and give
talks to adults
and we have a lot of resources for
educators our information unit is
responsible for our website basically
everything Communications website
videography social media all our events
planning including our Discover wild New
Hampshire Day event in April our Barry
Conservation Camp we manage that media
relations marketing and promotion um
including materials development our
Publications including our award-winning
magazine our Hunter and fishing digests
brochures all of it television and paid
media
merchandising podcast and radio content
uh we manage our landowner relations
program and we're also the liaison for
our official nonprofit partner the
wildlife Heritage
Foundation um if you'd like more
information please visit our website
which is fairly new and looks great at
wild.com and I've given all of you a
handout which is sort of an overview of
the our agency as a whole and happy to
questions representative Fox yes you're
recognized not really a question more of
a comment I love the magazine that you
guys put out um and it's one of the odd
things that I leave out in the house
everybody in my family actually reads it
that you're you're recognized Madam
Clark may I have your first and last
name again please Nicola Whitley n i c o
l a Whitley wh i i t l e
y any other
questions seeing none thank you very
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for having us today
my name is Kathy leonti and I am the
chief of the business Division I have
been with the department for
approximately 21 and a half years in
this role quite a long time the business
division is a support division to all
other divisions within the department
we're kind of that Cog that keeps things
going that doesn't get a lot of
recognition but we're very important we
have 13 full-time employees providing
three very distinct functions for the
department and they are licensing and
ohrv registrations all accounting
business and financial functions and
Fleet Management I have five full-time
staff that work within the licensing and
ohrv registration section for the
issuance and sale of fishing and hunting
licenses stamps and permits and ohrv
registrations we have approximately
350 agents throughout the state that
sell our licenses and ohrv
registrations other business functions
on the financial side is the support
which is the processing of all accounts
payable accounts receivable cash
management and banking as well as all
purchasing for goods and services for
everyone in the department we oversee
over 50 federal grants we do the
tracking and Reporting and receive
approximately $8 to 11 million in Grant
revenues annually in addition to other
grants in agency income and we also
oversee the arpa funding as well which
is coming to an end
quickly we also oversee all inventory
control accounting and Reporting all
contracts governor and Council items
fiscal committee items all flow through
my office and me we we do shipping and
receiving services and mail services for
the entire
department we also I also have two
full-time mechanics that service our
Fleet which with which has approximately
460 individual active pieces of
equipment including trucks ATVs
motorcycles boats
snowmobiles various types of trailers in
miscellaneous construction equipment I
work very closely with several other
state agencies including Das treasury
dncr Dees and others I myself personally
oversee and have a hand of in all of
this B business activity plus I oversee
the
submission and preparation of our
agency's banal budget and with that I
would entertain any questions you may
have thank you are there any questions
representative
Harvey um I'm glad to hear that you have
um mechanic to oversee all of the pieces
of equipment because there's quite a bit
when you pull into the fishing game
parking lot it's it's filled do you do
you have an inventory do you keep an
inventory of all of these 460 pieces of
equipment do you know what you have and
where they are and who's responsible for
them absolutely we do the state of New
Hampshire actually has what's called
fims the fleet information management
system and we are part of that as All
State agencies are separate from that we
keep a separate inventory system for our
own Department inventory but um all of
your ATVs trucks snow machines
everything is like kept in two different
places because we have Manu uh mandatory
excuse me reporting for the Department
of AD administrative Services annually
and all of that is included so if I see
a fishing game track followup oh I'm
sorry thank you it's been a while um so
if I see a fishing game uh truck parked
at Fishing Game Commission office in
Keen you know that it's it's checked out
or it's there or absolutely it is a sign
to an individual thank you you're
welcome I apologize Mr Mr chair no
problem we're all coming back from a
long
break any further questions
representative
ulette thank you for taking my question
um
when items in the fleet are going to be
retired or not used what's the process
to get rid of them that is called
Surplus and once it is deemed that that
piece of equipment is no longer usable
we have to go through a process of
surplus so the originating division who
own who is responsible for that piece of
equipment would fill out the proper
paperwork and it would go through a
system of being put into the state's
official Financial system for the state
called um um s in Surplus excuse me and
Farm any further questions um yes
representative
Murphy this is one question I'm just
curious motorcycles you mentioned what
for tvsa
trail bikes as well because the
advantage to that is they're Road worthy
so I can put an officer on one he can he
can work a trail system then he can drop
down onto the highway to go to a pond to
check fisherman so work so and we give
it to the licensed offers that are
licensed with it we do have okay thank
you welcome thank you any further
questions I have one myself yes sir can
you tell us when we can expect the ohrv
registrations to be transitioned to
online we are on on target for that
September of 25 date thank you I get
constant questions from constituents
about when that's going to be available
I'm sure you do and we are on target for
that sir thank you you're
welcome and with that I see no more
questions thank you very much for your
up good morning Mr chairman members of
the the committee um I'm happy to be
here my name is Randy Curtis I'm the
Department's federal aid administrator
and I'm responsible for administering uh
and coordinating our involvement in
federal aid programs you heard Kathy
mention just a moment ago about the
amount of federal money that we bring
into the agency through through grants
and um I'm going to talk a little bit
about that program
specifically uh my responsibilities are
to be knowledgeable regarding federal
laws and regulations and policies
related to the various federal aid
programs that we participate
in and I help the department prepare
Grant applications administer Grant
Awards during their period of
performance and then assist with
performance reporting and various uh
compliance requirements that come with
the federal funds and I typically serve
as a point of contact for uh various
federal agencies related to Grant
matters uh well you may not be aware
that every division within the
department has some level of federal
funding built into their operating
budget and as Kathy said we typically
have 40 to 50 active grants uh and
Cooperative agreements with uh that
cover a wide range of the Department's
uh
activities these include game management
projects Wildlife Research marine
fisheries projects freshwater Fisheries
projects environmental review and
technical assistance Fish Hatchery
production Marine law enforcement
boating access operation and maintenance
habitat management Wildlife Management
Area land acquisition operation of the
Great Bay National Estrin research
Reserve our hunter educ education
program aquatic education program and a
variety of non-game and endangered
Wildlife program so right there you can
see you can see the wide variety of uh
activities that the department is
involved
in many of our grants are long running
ongoing grants uh that fund basic
responsibilities for the Department
other grants are are one-time uh
projects for things like boat access
construction uh acquisition of land
equipment purchases for large equipment
items or specific Wildlife Research
projects uh just a few facts about uh
the department and the federal revenue
that we receive through through our
grant programs uh with the exception of
some extraordinary situation like uh
emergency relief funds or the op funding
that came uh through co uh in most
typical years uh the department received
receives nearly all of its Federal uh
Revenue through two uh from two federal
agencies from the fish and wildlife
service and then from uh Noah the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration and in most years about
75% of all of that federal revenue comes
from just two programs the wildlife
restoration program and the sportfish
restoration program that's the Pitman
Robertson Robertson act that you may
have heard of and the Dingle Johnson act
side those Pro those programs provide a
formula based funding uh Arrangement uh
it's based on the federal statutes and
there's an annual apportionment that's
based on the applicable uh tax revenues
that come into each of the
programs uh our other federal aid into
the department is based on um
Congressional Appropriations it dep just
depends on how much they fund the
particular Grant programs uh some of
those sources of funding are state
wildlife Grant GRS uh we have Noah
Fisheries grants for the Marine
division's work uh and some funding from
U the national Noah's National estu and
research Reserve
System uh but Federal a is a key part of
the fund uh the Department's operations
and it it does require a significant
administrative effort on the part of the
department uh myself and an assistant
end up working with uh all the division
Chiefs and project leaders in their
division as well as extensively with
Cathy's division because handles
probably the most important part of the
grants which is the whole reason for
them and that's the the federal
reimbursements that we get for our for
our
activities and with that I'm happy to
answer any questions great
representative Harvey I missed how many
people are in your department uh well
just in the federal aid program it it's
really a department-wide effort because
it's so involved but it's myself and an
assistant that work uh on on
coordinating the programs thank you no
follow
up and any further questions seeing none
thank you so much for your time thank
up good
morning uh my name is Mike Dion I'm the
environmental review coordinator for the
Department um I'm in the director's
office um I've been with the department
for 25 years my first 22 years as a
marine biologist out on the coast um in
my current role um I provide comments
and recommendations on various
environmental environmental reviews
throughout the state um these include
New Hampshire dot Bridge projects calber
projects um water withdraws like um at
ski
areas um I provide comments on um
aquatic herbicide application permits um
many energy projects throughout the
state including hydroelectric
solar and um wind um in addition to that
I uh represent the director and the
department on many boards and committees
uh these include the water Council
Wetland Council dredge task force Exotic
Aquatic weeds and species um drinking
water and groundwater Advisory Board um
and also the pesticide board I I'll take
any
questions thank you any questions
representative Harvey I didn't even
raised my hand yet again same question
how how many people uh I'm in the
director's office so it's just me I work
directly for the director with nobody
under me thank you anyone else
representative Jacobs could you repeat
your uh position again uh invironmental
review coordinator thank you
yep anyone
else seeing none thank you so much for
your time thank
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee um Dan buron I'm the chief of
the wildlife division I've been with the
department for about 12 years now I
started there as the deer biologist and
then transitioned over to the game
program supervisor um now I'm the chief
of the wildlife division um So within
the wildlife division we have
approximately 30 to 35 Staff um
depending on seasonals and if we're up
to full staff um we have five kind of
primary um um things we focus on so the
first which most people are probably
familiar with is our game Management
program and we also have non-game and
endangered species management uh land
conservation and habitat management um
we have a big data collection um entry
and Analysis um um section and then also
we do animal damage
control um our division is primarily
funded through dedicated licenses um
permit Revenue um but but as Randy had
mentioned the bulk of the money comes
from federal grants uh we really would
not be able to do the work that our
division does without the the federal
money um our budget um typically within
the wildlife division is about $7
million um which makes up about 177% of
the overall um Fish and Game
budget um so the different type of work
we do um so we manage Monitor and
conserve game species um including deer
bear moose turkey small game species fur
bear species and water fowl uh we cons
serve and monitor non-game and
endangered Wildlife um including things
like blandings turtle wood Turtles bald
eagles paragan Falcons New England
cotton Tails carer blue butterflies and
hundreds of other species um in in
conservation need um we also have a a
unit within the wildlife program that
does do some environmental review that's
specific to threaten an endangered
species um and that's related to state
funded activities and permitting
projects through other state
agencies um we also conserve and manage
Wildlife um habitat on over 60,000 Acres
of Fish and Game owned properties and
over 20,000 Acres of of land that's
under conservation
easements um we provide technical
assistance to different municipalities
industrial Forest land owners private
land owners that are interested in
wildlife habitat management um and then
we can serve high value wildlife
habitats through fee purchases um indoor
easements um and then we also provide
animal damage control assistance um so
sometimes that's through technical
assistance or we do have have permit
programs where agricultural Growers um
um can remove Wildlife that are causing
damage on their property um we have a
reimbursement program for Bare damage um
but we have one staff member um that
oversees that whole program um but then
also works cooperatively with the United
States Department of Agriculture
wildlife services here in
coner um we do a lot of research
um um the federal money that Randy had
mentioned again we we we've been very
good at leveraging that with different
universities so we've conducted um
numerous research projects for moose uh
deer bear furbearers numerous non-game
species um we have a current research
project going on looking at um cause
specific mortality in our Fisher
population that we're working with the
University of New Hampshire on um and a
lot of these research projects because
we're able to leverage the federal money
and then UNH provides the match um the
research is conducted at no cost to the
to the state or the agency um so it very
beneficial relationship and as as Kathy
and Randy pointed out um you know the
federal money we wouldn't be able to do
our work but we wouldn't be able to do
our work with with the with the um work
that they do um and we need 10 times
more ry's and Cathy in our agency um
with that I'll take any
questions representative Harvey when is
the results for this Fisher um project
when can we expect to see the results
from from that so it just got underway
um they're still in the process of
trying to capture and put collars on on
animals um so it'll be at least another
two years before we start to see any
Real Results um so um with most of the
research most of our research is usually
typically you know two to three years um
um often times we'll expand those so
Moose for example we've been kind of
consistently doing research on moose um
who puts the collar on the Fishers um so
it's it's usually um it varies but it's
typically it'll be the UNH uh graduate
students and advisers and then staff um
sometimes assist depending on the need
and and
availability hope they have good medical
insurance uh any further questions
representative ulette thank you for
taking my question you had mentioned
that the fish game department has 60,000
Acres of property and 20,000 acres in
conservation is is a that part of the
program to continually um purchase
additional properties and is there a set
goal in the long term what you want to
own a set goal in terms of the amount of
property we want to own um there's no
set goal really um our like most of our
programs um we're we're underst staffed
um one of the things we've kind of
shifted towards a little bit more in
recent years is stewardship of those
properties um um we've added a few
additional staff um over the last few
years a land surveyor um we we have a
staff member that can go out and do some
more kind of um you know small level
road work and and maintenance things on
our property so there's no specific goal
um we kind of we kind of pick up
properties you know we we look at we
look at different pieces of lands in
relation to other conservation land and
the benefit to different species
throughout the state so there's no
target um the amount of land we're
looking to own which really kind of um
as properties come up we look at the
value our ability to purchase it um we
we often times work with other partners
um different um um land conservation
groups um so again we can leverage
additional funds um but no no specific
Target for the amount of land we're
looking to
own representative Harvey does that
conservation land include um access to
waterways or is that going to be covered
by a different
division um some of it will um but but
not necessarily so there's boat access
as well which is which is different and
then um the Fisheries division has some
um some habitat stuff they do as well
and if we can coordinate with other
divisions where where those interests
might align we'll we'll consider that
but um it's not a primary focus but some
of the land just you know because of
where it's located we'll have access to
waterways but may I ask a followup
please followup so can you tell me how
much you may not be able to break it
down that far but is is out of those
880,000 Acres can you tell me how much
is access to waterways either um boat
access
or swimming or whatever I could look
into that for you I do not have that
number kind of off the top of my head
but I'd appreciate that thank you yeah
it it would would you be interested
would you be able to email me
specifically what you're interested in
and we can look into it that'd be great
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh there was some
discussion in my district uh last season
about few years ago we heard that there
was some uh disease coming towards this
way deer bone you know like a bone
marrow type uh disease through deer what
is the situation now that um uh if you
can update us that so there's um my son
is that that's a reference to chronic
wasting disease um so we do we do annual
surveillance in the state um we we
typically try and Sample about 400 Deer
annually and we'll get deer heads from
butchers cooperating butchers throughout
the state during the hunting season then
our biological staff will remove samples
we send those out to a lab for testing
um so through our surveillance we also
will test um you know any symptomatic
animals that the public might might
report um through our surveillance we
have not detected chronic wasting
disease in the state to date um one of
the biggest risks of that coming into
the state is captive um servid or
captive members of the deer family so
those are things like um moose white
tailed deer mule deer elk Red Deer
reindeer those are all species that are
susceptible to disease um currently
under our import um regulations we do
not allow the importation of any servid
um that is susceptible to CWD uh we also
have restrict on Hunters about what
they're allowed to bring back from
different served species from CW known
CWD positive States um so you can only
bring back um you know Taxidermy mounts
um essentially it's all low lowrisk
tissue samples so things like Meats
taxid mounts antlers um cleaned out
skulls things like that and it's all um
an effort to prevent the introduction of
that disease
unfortunately um that disease does kind
of continue to creep AC across the
country the closest that's been to New
Hampshire was Quebec um it was
discovered in a captive deer um I
believe it was a captive Red Deer farm
in Quebec um several years ago um
they've done significant testing around
that facility um it cost them millions
of dollars to do to do additional
culling of the herd and testing and
fortunately they have not found it in
any wild deer in Quebec um New York
prior to that was the closest that it
had been um um and they had been they
had not documented another case of CWD I
think since um 2009 or so but
unfortunately they just detected another
um CWD positive deer in a captive
facility thank you
representative thank you for taking my
question um going back to um purchasing
property for um if you find a desirable
piece of property where does the capital
come from to purchase property
so we have the
$22.50 um habitat fee um that folks pay
on on all their licenses that fee is um
it's $2.50 and it's um 20 it's been that
way for 25 years um so that is some of
the money um a good portion of the money
comes from the federal the pr dollars
Pitman Robertson dollars um will utilize
um we can use um so if we get bargain
sales on property um we can use the the
sale of those prop properties um um as
long as there was no other federal funds
used to purchas sometimes we'll get
donations which is another thing so land
donations um we have had individuals
will donate um money on their own to
provide match for properties um
typically we need to come up with about
25% of the cost and then the federal
funds cover the rest of it um um but
we'll work with other groups like um TNC
for society different um um land
conservation funds and things to come up
questions seeing none thank you so much
thank
up good morning chairman committee my
name is Diane Timmons I have been
working for the Department for almost 30
years 24 of that was a field biologist
started in Keen worked my way to the
Lakes Region and then up North for 21
years and then uh unfortunately decided
that I would take an administrative
position and I've been in conquered for
the last four it's been a great
adventure but so uh my division is the
Inland Fisheries division we don't do
any Marine we do all the Inland stuff we
have um six programs that work
underneath me and they include warm
water species management cold water
species
management um Fish Conservation which
includes are non-game species so minnows
um species of greatest
concern um as well as some others eels
and anris and kadis fish then we also
have fish habitat and then we also have
the large lakes program in The Lakes
Region which includes our landlock
salmon and lake trout programs
so I have 39 staff members nine of those
are in my biological staff the other are
the others are in the Hatchery so I
oversee both components of Inland
Fisheries the um other work that we do
Under the biological staff is surveys we
go out into different water bodies we
look at stream Crossings we work with
other state agencies to look and manage
as to whether AOSS in should stay or go
we work with communities to acquire
grants to get those um culs restored or
removed and um in the process of doing
that obviously looking to improve
habitat for fish species also safety for
people we also work with universities
across the state as well as other states
collaborative efforts and in doing that
we look at genetics research we look at
migration research for various wild brck
trout populations Etc just trying to
provide opportunities for our Anglers
throughout the
state we also work on Rural Development
and um again with the end goal of
managing our species populations while
providing recreational opportunities for
various
folks and we also look at stocking so
the various water bodies that folks
angle and we need to get you out maybe
we start with a show poool at the
Hatchery little bit of interest they
really big fish and um anyway so we do
the stocking as well across the state so
our hatcheries uh we have six of those
and four of which are over a hundred
years old I should start with all of
them are in the historic realm now so uh
they four are over 100 one is about 75
and the other one is 53 years old so our
youngest Hatchery is in Milford our
oldest Hatchery is in Warren so we have
a quite a diversity of a lot of um
infrastructure issues as well as you
know trying to maintain our numbers and
our stocking targets for folks and
speaking of infrastructure if I could
digress for one moment I did create a
spreadsheet for our infrastructure
committee and I can work with danan to
make sure you get that because that
provides all the land conservation who
it is what it is and where it is and we
can I can get that to you
um so one of the other things that we
are working on I'm sure most of you have
heard about it is the arpa project for
the New Hampton Fish Hatchery
modernization effort um I'm happy to say
that yesterday I was at a site team
meeting and in the background was a
bunch of excavators dismantling
equipment so we are officially breaking
ground which is pretty exciting um it's
a going to be a fantastic facility uh
right now at New Hampton we produce
about 75,000 lb uh currently it's
completely closed there are no fish on
station for anybody to see um and they
that will take about two years to get
the project completed but in that
process we will more than double our
capacity at that particular location it
will have heavy
duty heavy duty filtration and um it
will actually be our best hatchery in
the state as far as meeting our
compliance with their nipes permits for
various phosphorus and um nitrogen
limits that we currently struggle with
at this point so and with that um Randy
had mentioned we do work with Randy and
Kathy on various grants and um also with
our various non-governmental
organization partners and other state
agency partners to get a bunch of work
done because we can't do it all under
our current budget so that helps and
it's a great collaboration and
Partnerships but that I'll take any
questions any questions representative
oulette thank you for taking my question
sure um it's nice to hear about the New
Hampton project and um a lot was done
with the pow Mill project yes and um I
know they're very expensive but do you
have a long-term plan to to Really
redo the others there are some that are
very deteriorated in this state and
they're kind of embarrassing
all of them are so um I would my answer
to you is absolutely so the hatcheries
are in locations where they are for
various efficiency purposes so we have
um hatcheries in the north hatchery in
well Hatchery is in the north Hatcher's
in the south of course Central and then
east and west and so as we go through
the progress and the and the future and
as this comes about we'll be really
analyzing how we can make this work with
the budgets that we have and the
struggles with we have with you know
getting these things repaired or
replaced uh the New Hampton project we
started out with a 25 million estimate
and ended up with a $58 million final
project so it it's very very much
expensive and um but we'll be looking at
all of that at this point that's our
plan is to just kind of come up with a
program where we can keep what we
can follow up thank
you who's uh who's next on your target I
have no
idea no in all honesty powdermill is not
going away it's our best water source so
we're hoping that we can get funding but
of course arpa is uh probably a once in
my career opportunity so we'd be looking
for uh major funding sources elsewhere
but Powder Mill is probably our next
just cuz it was our largest facility it
covers the largest geographic area and
right now it's uh less than a third of
its production due to permitting
issues representative Harvey do you do
you get money then from
Dingle I get money yes yes from DJ funds
yep any other questions if I could
follow up on that so just so you know so
it's a little bit different than
wildlife in that we're a New Hampshire's
a minimal state so my capacity to get
funding is much less than it is for um
excuse me for wildlife so just so folks
understand they are two different
funding mechanisms and the programs and
the capacities of each program is
different so our Fisheries money the
taxes that come in on that money is much
less than the money that comes in from
big guns and bullets and that type of
stuff so Fisheries
unfortunately is a much less pot much
lower pot to pick
from thank you any other questions I
have one myself sure the new filtration
that's heavy duty yes did we end up
going with a mechanical chemical
filtration or did we go with an organic
we went with a dinos Sand Filtration so
it's well it's both so we have heavy
duty filters that first start the
process and then it goes through
Sand Filtration that use utilizes
aluminum to bind to the phosphorus the
solids and then remove it from there
thanks yep seeing no other questions
thank you very much for your time today
thank
up are we ending with you Colonel I
believe the commission is going to come
behind me but yes she was unsure if she
would be able to sneak over here but I
her an open invitation for all day long
so she perfect perfect uh yes our
director currently is at governor and
Council I believe but her her goal is to
get here uh at some point so I'm going
to represent two divisions today the
Marine Division I'll start with because
our Marine Division Chief uh is away
with a lot of her staff at a conference
in Washington DC so I asked her to give
me some notes so please forgive me I'm
going to read what she's given me here
but a marine divisions Fisheries
division is responsible for managing
conserving and protecting the natural
resources and habitats of the state's
Coastal Waters the harbors and the
estuaries the division operates out of
the Region 3 office which is located in
Durham and manages and develops
monitoring programs for important
recreational and Commercial fisheries
and marine species as well as protecting
those precious habitats as part of the
responsibilities for fisheries
management of ocean species the division
is a collaborative partner with the
Atlantic states marine fisheries
Commission and the New England uh
fisheries management Council and making
management decisions for many migratory
marine species to further the the
understanding of some important species
the division conducts research
collaboratively with those Partners uh
the Marine Division Licenses and
monitors aquaculture in partnership with
the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services and New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
it also oversees the Great Bay national
uh Estrin research Reserve known as
gibner uh the research program focuses
on understanding the structure and
functions of the Great Bay uh ecosystems
and the effects of natural and human
induced changes to that system the
reserve researches and mon re the
reserves research and monitoring efforts
focus on four themes water quality land
use change biological communities and a
changing ecosystem the Great Bay
Discovery Center hosts a variety of
educational programs throughout the year
which are designed to teach young
visitors and students about the unique
natural and cultural resources of the
Great Bay Estuary 10,000 plus acres of
land protection within gibner supports
uh maintaining or improving habitat
conditions and water quality within the
Great Bay
Watershed so that's the Marine Division
and that would be Sheree Patterson that
sorry
questions are you doing he I'm sure
he'll do his best to answer for Sheree
if you've got a question for for that
right uh so I that was my question for
you was are you taking it at after each
division or after he's totally we can do
it after each division so if you'd like
to ask your question go ahead thank you
uh thank you Mr chair so um oh shoot now
my oh yes I know um f first of all um
the Great Bay Estuary is a wonderful
place and Once Upon a Time our committee
visited and it was it's fantastic but my
question is um I couldn't write fast
enough Atlantic state marine fisheries
and there was another um uh so it works
in conjunction with uh Atlantic State's
marine fisheries commission and then New
England fisheries management
decisions any other
questions seeing none you can go ahead
with your own now yeah so now this is
one I do know a little something about
it's a law division uh it's the largest
division in the agency and if you
haven't figured out as we've been going
through this uh this is a heck of a team
over there um you know if you enjoy the
deer population that we haven't seen
since I was a kid that's because of Dan
and his team if you enjoy good fishing
opportunities which I know a lot of you
do that's we can thank Diane and her
team Kathy Keeps Us squared away and
pays our bills and makees sure I can buy
equipment for my staff which is critical
for our function Randy gets US Federal
money when we can't get State money
um so without this group working
together and Nicola puts out all of our
press releases that you're going to see
if you haven't seen um and does all of
our public education so it is a good
working unit over there with a very it's
a very close family frankly uh and I
feel very fortunate to be a part of it
so in the law division we have 48
full-time positions uh to cover the
entire state currently we have 38
working in the field as field officers
um I have four headquarters staff the
colonel major Captain and an
administrative Lieutenant everybody else
is in the field uh right now we have six
openings that we're trying to
fill um just to give you an idea the
city of conquer has 70 police officers
to cover the city and we're trying to do
the entire state with 38 um so we're wul
short um we enforce all hunting fishing
and trapping regulations Statewide we
have six uh districts within our state
and each district has a lieutenant and a
sergeant and field officers those
districts start in Coos County and work
their way down to the coast so we cover
everything from uh the Canadian border
to the mass border to the main border
and over to
Vermont we also have motor vehicle
powers to enforce Motor Vehicle Laws
although we I kind of discourage that
unless they see something that's an
emergency somebody driving impaired or
someone driving recklessly I don't want
them out running radar um because we
have many more other things that we want
them doing but they do have that
Authority they're very active in
community policing roles we do a lot of
presentations and a lot of community
events I I think that's a valuable
service and fishing game historically
was not real active in that we have
become a lot more active I I think
that's an important piece we handle most
of the nuisance animal calls that are
receiv received throughout the state
everything from a uh from a groundhog in
my garden to a bear on my front
porch uh along with real Good Help from
the wildlife staff on those issues we do
all the rabies investigations we process
suspected animals and transport them for
testing when someone has a bad encounter
with a with a wild animal we enforce all
the ATV and OHV laws so we Patrol on
snow machines and ATVs and dirt bikes as
we talked about earlier to enforce speed
regulations on our Trail systems we we
monitor for registration uh compliance
and we cover all the off Highway uh
recreational accidents that
occur we participate in all the outdoor
education classes to include hunter
safety trapping safety OHV safety
classes and the letx go fishing programs
as well as the becoming an outdoor
woman's program uh there are law
segments in each one of those and we
have officers go in uh at the various
programs to teach we do the Inland
Fisheries boat enforcement we also do of
course fishing enforcement so uh and
chairman Spain if you get yourself to a
show poool I really would like to know
that cuz I'd like to watch you with a
pair of binoculars just so we can make
sure that you don't do anything foolish
you should try fishing sir you would
enjoy it you would be very good at it I
used to when I was younger yeah you know
it's a difference between fishing and
pulling in hornpout right there you
go uh we do a lot on the coast um we do
a lot of coastal enforcement we work in
partnership with marine fisheries as
well as Noah National Oceanic
Atmospheric Administration to Monitor
and enforce commercial fishing laws
Randy uh helps us with federal grants we
receive we average about a half a
million quarter to a half a million
dollars every year from the feds to
enforce uh Coastal regulations which is
a big savings for the State of New
Hampshire we use that money to purchase
valuable equipment and to equip and pay
our officers to be down there we work we
enforce all the commercial Fisheries
along the laws along the coast we have
multiple watercraft down there that we
use to patrol and conduct searches in
the ocean waterways to include two
substantial safe boat crafts for foul
weather on the ocean all of the officers
down there go to extensive training and
are certified in the operation of those
boats as well as Marine law enforcement
enforcement from our federal partners by
attending the federal law enforcement
training center in Glenco Georgia so
they're well trained in the operation of
those bigger
boats one thing we're probably most
known for is search and rescue Statewide
anything from Lost persons to carry out
for injured hikers uh we cover all the
walkways The Runaways basically anything
that occurs off the highways in the
state become our responsibility things
like plane CL crashes major flooding
events or weather events and we are very
active over at New Hampshire Emergency
Operations Center as the lead in the
state for search and rescue
operations uh we have a number of
specialized teams I'll just touch on
them quickly we have an advanced search
and rescue team which is a group of
officers that we have trained at at
levels far above the normal game warden
to go above Tree Line in in adverse
weather as they just did Sunday night
that you I'm sure you saw in the news we
have the only state dive team even
though we're called New Hampshire State
Police dive team on the news on on
occasion it's very frustrating because
we have the only team fishing game has a
dive recovery team we just recently
finished uh purchasing a
state-of-the-art trailer with the
ability to fill our own tanks at the
scene which has been a big bonus it's
been a project of mine since I became
the colonel and we have that now so um
we have some really Advanced uh diving
equipment and some good divers these
divers are trained to dive in all
conditions including under the ice uh
which is incredibly dangerous we have an
airboat rescue team with two airboats
that were purchased through Homeland
Security so those are boats that will go
out on thin ice uh and travel across
land and in flood conditions so we use
those a number of times I have a team of
officers trained to operate those we've
been able to achieve five currently K9
teams which which I'm very proud of I'm
very proud of all of these people I got
to tell you I I uh say it all the time
they're the best people in the world to
work with I have men and women now I'm
very happy to say I have three of the uh
three female officers that are absolute
firecrackers and uh they are given the
boys will run for their money um and one
of them is is on that uh looking to be
on that K9 team but our K9 team is
called by all kinds of state agencies
we've been involved in many high-profile
homicide cases was rc9 that found the
murder weapon for that young man that
murdered his family in Northfield and
drove down 93 and threw the gun out in
the medium I had two canines that spent
three days going up and down the medium
of the highway and they found the gun
that led to the arrests they also played
a pivotal role in the conquered
homicides the double homicides for the
folks walking on the trail they found
all the evidence that was used in that
conviction so these dogs I'm very proud
of these dogs they're not bite dogs
they're search dogs uh and they're very
good at at what they do
we have an honor guard team which we use
in formal ceremonies and flag folding a
flag folding team that joins with them
we have a sidescan sonar team which is a
specialized technical equipment used for
underwater searching it's some of the
most advanced underwater searching that
exists today I have an officer who's
very good at it uh he solved a couple of
coal cases when we were missing people
for over 30 years he was able to locate
them using this equipment uh this
involves uh radar searching under the
water as well as uh remote Vehicles
operating with cameras on board to to
search we have a drone team which is a
new team uh I have four individuals
including two pilots that fly drones for
search and rescue we're starting to get
into that is using a drone to as another
resource for search missions we have
cameras uh night vision cameras that are
mounted on this and GPS navigation
equipment um and then finally we have a
ja which is a joint enforcement team of
officers train throughout the state to
go down and work on our Coastline as the
the rules and laws down there are
complicated so it takes a uh in advance
training really to be effective with
that and we have a group of officers
that have taken on that additional
challenge so in a nutshell that's that's
uh the law enforcement
division thank you
questions representative
KH Mr chairman it's not a question just
I'm going to make a comment is it okay
go ahead thank you Mr chairman uh
Coronel Jordan I come from a district
where uh my residents or anybody who has
license can catch a 800B tuna and
equally if they want to hunt a deer a
200b deer they can find in my district
also you know it's a unique place and
this is my opportunity to appreciate all
the men and wom of your department who
enforce the hunting and fishing law and
we see day in and day out we we
appreciate all the men and wom who is
making that happen thank you thank you
sir next uh representative
Tudor thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question when you said you
had six openings is that going to be an
addition to the 48 or are those that
would be the total of 48 so right now I
have 42 total but we have we're funded
for 48 so we're looking to hire six more
um and you know where in fact I'm going
to leave you some pamphlets because
everybody knows somebody right if you
know someone who's interested in this
job I don't care if they think they can
get it or not encourage them to call me
they can call me personally I take take
these calls all the time I want to talk
to these kids um we're always looking
for good people and and I'm going to
leave you this which kind of tells you
uh what's required of them so please
take advantage of that so one thing I
wanted to say Sir was we we're fortunate
New Hampshire fishing game when I get
them I keep them they don't go a lot of
agencies lose them we don't do that um
I'm very lucky that we're we're a close
Bunch uh we work very hard to keep them
happy so it's just finding them as my
challenge once I get them we we keep
them so if you know of anyone please
encourage them to
call representative
Harvey is your equipment included in the
inventory that I asked about earlier yes
so we have we put uh numbers practically
on everything that we own with the
exception of consumables so cuz our
officers this division is equipped
really from head to toe toe uh takes 2
days to outfit a new officer with all
the equipment so that equipment is
tracked annually they're responsible for
their own equipment so an officer can be
issued a boat or or more than one boat
depending on his Patrol he'll be issued
an ATV and or a motorcycle depending on
his Patrol a snow machine a four-wheel
drive Cruiser uh and tons of search and
rescue equipment and uniforms guns and
all of that equipment is is very closely
monitored yes thank you followup please
followup uh I forget the name of the
program um that was on television
Northwoods law yes is it is it still
airing so yeah well two things are
happening so nor the big mistake Kevin
Jordan made when we signed up for
Northwoods laws I didn't do anything
about the reruns I found out uh about
television the money is made in the
reruns not in the because it keeps going
and we didn't we didn't do anything with
that so we gave that to them free
however the company has returned because
the demands for the show have been great
which is kind of interesting so they are
we are in the middle of a contract
negotiation uh but it looks like it's
going to happen for us to return the
only difference being we're going to be
on YouTube which I'll never see but
we're going to be on YouTube um and that
is the new thing in television is
YouTube so I'm looking forward to it
because I have a a whole uh a whole
number of new staff uh and they have
come up and met some of the staff and
they're excited about it and some of
these kids want to do it and I I think
it's a great opportunity I think it I
think it does a couple of things for the
state I think it promotes the state of
New Hampshire certainly because it shows
the natural resources and I also think
it gives the officers a lot of the
credit that they that all officers
deserve for the great job they do and
people don't realize it until you see it
on a television show so um so yes it is
coming
back me
too representative DeVito
regarding the six openings that you have
what do you think the difficulties are
in finding those those candidates to you
know it's getting hard and I I don't
understand we we're all looking at it
everybody's looking at it when we when
we meet with any other agency the
colonel of State Police I meet with
regularly and we're all struggling with
it we don't understand it I think some
of it has to do with the kids today are
smarter frankly I think they can make
more money doing other things and
they're looking at that I think another
thing that has heard us is uh some we
did to ourselves some of the hits that
law enforcement has taken for mistakes
they've made and some of the UN you know
they they're viewed in some areas as not
being very popular and I think these
kids are a little intimidated by that um
we offer great benefits we offer good
salary um we're buying you know
everything but but very few articles of
clothing you're driving home with a
cruiser there are huge benefits to it it
does have demands when you ask someone
to go above tree line at 60 below um you
know not everybody wants to do that and
so that that creates some issues but
yeah we're we're all working on
recruiting my major today is at three
different schools high schools trying to
encourage high school kids to take a
look at this career so we're working
pretty hard at it I don't I don't think
anybody has the answer
yet follow up your search dogs are those
the plot hounds so we now we have Labs
um I I love those dogs by the way that's
my favorite part of the job they're all
Labs I have every color lab um which is
you know they're donated dogs I remember
one of the kennel operators said listen
I you know I got another dog for you but
I really hate to tell you he's yellow
he's a yellow lab I said listen the
quality of these dogs I don't care if
he's purple send him our way if you can
do it so the LA labs are donated uh the
officers put in a lot of time on their
own and training and housing cuz that's
a fulltime job seven days a week they
take these dogs home I let them keep the
dogs I fought hard to do that cuz I
think they're their dogs um and they
they build a bond that doesn't change
like your dog um and so they are all
Labs but they're trained in evidence
detection they're trained in Wildlife
detection so they can distinguish deer
meat from regular meat U they can find
moose meat they can find fish uh we are
working I've been told or asked I've
been asked by my team leader to write a
memorandum of understanding they want to
work with the medical examiner's office
on cadavers they want to start working
so we have a team ready to search for
bodies um and and the unlike most other
teams in the state they train weekly
most places do it monthly my lieutenants
complain about that because it takes
these guys out of the field but I think
that's what makes them better they train
harder and they only train in those
fields so they're going to be the best
at it um what I like about them is I can
bring them in here today would lap all
of you to death they would jump up on
you they're friendly dogs uh until you
put that vest on and then they go to
work but they're not the liability part
of it doesn't exist uh for me so which
is good I don't have to worry about him
biting uh or doing anything the kids
love them and uh they're great to work
with we enjoy them we just recently lost
one I lost Ruger uh which tore my heart
out we had him for 12 years I think it
was 12 years Ruger was one of the
beginning dogs he was one of my favorite
dogs
um and he just passed away at the age of
12 so we're going to honor him soon
you'll see that I'm sure
so thank you any other questions
representative
oulette thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question yes sir um I
was uh involved with some general
contractors at the State of New
Hampshire and they instituted an intern
program for high school and college kids
and they found that the retention after
these kids get out of college was very
high once they found found a home before
or while they were in college have you
ever instituted something like that
we've been doing it actually sir so the
problem with an internship is that it's
a huge commitment of ours I just did it
for personally I did it because I didn't
want to ask a field officer to do it for
a student uh out of Plymouth State and
she is working as a dispatcher at marrat
County she'll probably spend her career
there so there is value in it I I would
agree I've got another one that I'm
reaching out to that is interested in
doing it um we do a lot of ridealong
programs a lot of um you know reduced
not a full internship but reduced hours
um D and our HR department has developed
a whole program so when we take on an
intern she has a whole package for me
that we fill out and do so we are
looking at doing that I think I agree
with you I think that has had some
success and we're trying to do that
problem is when you have limited staff
it's hard to you know because I can't
take them above tree lines so if we send
one of these officers on a mission you
have to think about that um how we're
doing that but we are starting to do
that I agree with you I think it's a
great
tool okay
followup thank you uh could you just
take a minute and and speak to us on the
success and challenges of your hike Safe
program yes so I I would like to thank
this committee for hike safe I came here
for the new members I came here for 20
years complaining that we weren't funded
enough for search and rescue and and we
can always use more money for that those
missions are a very Prett expensive they
involve a lot of overtime they involve a
lot of resources uh some of those
missions can run anywhere they can run
the range from $500 to $50,000 depending
on how long we're in it and what we're
doing um and so my repeated attempts at
coming to the legislature asking for
funding resulted in a the idea of a hike
safe card we have a excuse me a hike
Safe program which was kind of an
educational program telling people what
to put in their packs how to hike safely
we I kind of fought to name this card
after that program for Branding purposes
to keep it all in one program so they
could buy a card and and read the
educational piece at the same time uh
this committee was instrumental in
helping me get that set up the hike safe
card so we sell a card for you're going
to hear a little testimony later this
morning or today on on this card we're
going to make a little change in it um
but we sell a card for
$25 uh person and I think it's 35 for a
family um and the idea of this was that
47% of our search and rescue missions
were for hikers and climbers and they
were not paying into the system our
fishermen and our Hunters were paying
the bill and so I didn't feel that that
was fair now now with and this is a
voluntary thing people don't have to do
it but they they can and it makes them
part of the system they're now
contributing to the cost of this this
has amounted to
$300,000 this past year infused into my
search and rescue budget which was a big
bonus so uh the two young ladies that we
saved Sunday night on Mount Washington
at 60 below that were caught up there in
chest deep snow the first words out of
their mouth when we arrived on scen was
that they both had a hike Safeguard um I
would have never build them anyway but
but that's the the importance that
people put on it so it's been a it's
been a great tool I have to thank this
committee for the original idea I think
representative Spain was on the
committee when that started um and uh
it's been a great
success thank you any other
questions
yes it look like you're uh you're
lacking officers you have more officers
more money more resources upgraded
equipment and I thank you for coming
here don't be scared to ask ask us for
the help CU we'll give you oh I I won't
be you will find I'm anything SC I'm all
for you thank you very much whatever you
need I talk to your officers a lot yeah
and they tell me that they they don't
have enough men to cover right and there
a lot of poaching going on a lot of
everything going on right I think you
need it I think you need more offices
more resources upgraded equipment thank
you whatever you need I would support
you thank you I I do say I and I'm I'm
winding down in my career but I but I
will tell you with great confidence we
are the best equipped the best trained
and the best paid frankly that we've
ever been so we've made some great
strides and and and it's been through
the help of the legislature for that we
can use more people we're I'm breaking
up people hiking uh I've got I've lost
two officers to disabilities from
multiple injuries you continually send a
guy up Falling Waters Trail and and
eventually his knees are going to go or
in my case I did it for many years both
my shoulders went i' had to have him
have him rebuilt you know you can't you
can only do that so long and the more
people that you have the more you can
spread out that wealth um and you may
not injure the same people repeatedly so
um so that would be a big help as more
people but we are very well paid we are
very well equipped I think we fight hard
for that um but we can always use
everybody behind me could use more staff
that's for sure there's only I think
there's like 250 people over there doing
amazing amazing work Statewide and we
all benefit from
it thank you any other
questions thank you all for your time I
appreciate it very much thank leave
these sir if I could absolutely if you
anyone knows of anyone please encourage
them to call us you can pass those
around that's not a problem and thank
you for your time today
again it makes it easier people watching
on video can also hear okay while six
divisions were represented here at
fishing game today we do have a seventh
division called facilities and lands and
unfortunately the division Chief
position has been vacant for three and a
half four years so they are not
represented today but that is where our
public boat access program is housed as
well as a small construction crew and a
couple of guys that go around the state
to our Regional Offices fixing things as
well as um facility maintenance at our
headquarters on Hazen Drive I just
so if you know of anybody who would like
a division Chief position absolutely
thank
you with that I think we're done the
department orientation part correct was
nice having you all here today I know
you've got jobs to get back to so I'm
you and we now can hear from some of the
commission if the commission members
good morning and I thank the committee
for having us here representative Spain
my name is Ray
green I am the fishing game commissioner
for Hillsboro
County I am also the the current chair
of the fishing Game
Commission I have been on the commission
now just over 7 and a half
years I started that when I first became
on the
commission I got
luckily appointed onto the legislative
committee I then after a year of that I
was placed as the chair of the
legislative committee for the commission
I then took a year of being chairman of
the fishion Game Commission and then
after that one year commissioner stole
took it for a year this year he gave it
back
um but the commission is is we
are each county is represented by a
commissioner we have 11 Commissioners
currently right now we have 10 we have a
vacancy for the Rockingham County but
the commission is a 10 Commissioners
representing each county in the state
and plus we have a seast commissioner
seast the function of the commission is
that we are there for the management of
the wildlife but we're also there as the
representatives for the public we have
the go between between when public
has questions with fishing game they can
come through their
commissioner their commissioner then
brings it to fishing
game
so we hear from the public
constantly and we're the ones that we
work with fishing
game my job as chairman of the fishing
Game Commission is I am also the liazon
to the director of fishing
game so it works as a organized group on
getting information going
through and my background which I'm sure
everybody likes to
hear when I was a child as a
deterrent I was made to go into
commercial
fishing my uncle felt that kid needs
some
discipline I don't know if anybody is
done commercial fisherman fishing it is
a very LoveHate
relationship what was supposed to be a
deterrent did not
work I grew up as a commercial
fisherman from there I revolved over and
I did 20 years of law
enforcement my law enforcement career
was not fishing
game I can
constantly Jive the commissioner behind
police and then from there I also had a
business and what my business was and
that was actually was water
conservation I did lawn irrigation was
very involved with the irrigation
Association
National I was on their legislative
committee down in
Washington and worked with a lot of
legislation on conserving water
conserving soil
conditions and I can probably say I was
that dealing with Washington when you go
in and you have for an example you buy a
refrigerator today and it's energy
certified I was able to get three
different irrigation controllers under
that program that are energy certified
on conserving water so basically in my
whole lifetime I have been involved with
legislation and hard work the reason why
I became a commissioner
is I have three
daughters I also have four
granddaughters I'm outnumbered at my
house I have one son my thing is that I
grew up doing a little bit of hunting my
major fishing was saltwater fishing out
on the Sea Coast when my grandchildren
started to get big enough I started to
fishing my thing was that we need to
keep a future for the future
generations and that's why I got
involved with being a fishing game
commissioner and I'm open to any
questions thank you any questions for
representative
Harvey so I hear you tell me that you
know and I think you're paraphrase
paraphrasing which is okay that the
purposes of the fishing Game Commission
is a management of Wildlife and to act
as a representative of the public um but
your mission is also stated in statute
as well correct yes it is
followup followup
um I was looking it up and I couldn't
find it fast enough can you uh tell me
what this uh
statute um what the mission of the
you are you saying under statute what
are the duties of the commission we are
there to manage the
wildlife and uh we also there as like a
legaz on to the public I cannot sit here
and recite the whole statute of ra L let
me um it also has let me redirect this
Brad can you pull up the statute
definition for Fishing Game Commission
so that the committee can hear what it
quicker be under that or no it's not
this should be something that says
commission it was in the beginning 2062
I believe it
was
number
yeah action you're getting that there
you
go under the statute of 2062
the commission shall consist of 11
262a we're appointed by the governor and
the executive
councel and the way that is done is that
we get Nom you know we'll get
nominated from the governor to the
executive councel once the nomination is
made to the executive Council
um the nomination is held for 30 days
for anybody from the public that wants
to put input into it and after 30 days
the executive Council will then vote on
whether or not we become a
commissioner and you know as with
executive counsel obviously it's you
organization sometimes it points to the
sporting clubs in each C County May from
a county sporting club board whenever an
appointment is to be made to the
commission each board May nominate one
to three persons submitted for such
recommendation of the
governor um then when you get down into
further and like I said this is rather
lengthy so I'll I'll get down to I think
what I'm ask asking what you're looking
for representative harv is um the
qualifications is that
correct I'm sorry maybe I'm not being
clear um I don't need you to read 2062
because I can look it up as well thank
you um so maybe I didn't State my
question correctly can I try restating
it absolutely thank you so um
you know I've read that passage a
million times but maybe I'm asking um
because you are the New Hampshire
fishing Game
Commission there is um there is a
mission statement for New Hampshire
fishing game and I don't have it at the
tip of my tongue but it's something
about bringing the
outdoors to to everyone and that that's
that's the one I I think I'm asking for
what what is the overall mission
statement
for New Hampshire fishing
game I don't know the exact overall
mission statement for the fishing game
department because technically we
are we are separate from the Hampshire
fishing game department we have a
fishing game
commission and we are also part of I
believe it's three
regulatory commissions in the state of
New Hampshire we want of three we have
the fishing Game Commission the New
Hampshire Lottery Commission and the
Public Utilities Commission that were
under
regulatory we are not and and and this
is the easiest way to explain it we are
not a part of New Hampshire fishing game
in fact in statute it says the Fish and
Game
Commission um also looks at the the
overall operation of fishing game if you
go back on the history of New Hampshire
fishing game and the fishing Game
Commission try not to quote me on this
one but I believe was back in the
1800s it was a fishing game commission
that it
started and when the fishing Game
Commission
started it was also each Town had to
have a fishing game commissioner for
each town so I imagine somewhere along
the line you take the amount of towns
and cities in the state of New Hampshire
let narrow this down and it became the
fishing Game
Commission and then years down the road
from that it became the fishing game
department Under The Fishing Game
Commission and that's actually the way
it still reads
today thank you followup um it's not a
question um members of the committee
pointed it out to me it's it's actually
on the brochure that you gave us thank
you thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you so much
up good morning Mr chairman honorable
members of this committee my name is
Eric stall I'm represent Coos County and
I'm very happy to see three members of
Coos County on this committee especially
my representative Vice chairman wette I
actually had to make sure we didn't have
a committee full of Coos
County I wish the whole committee was
full of Coos County it wouldn't give
Fair representation to the rest of the
State uh I'm a retired conservation
officer I had about 30 years of service
retired at the rank of of Lieutenant
matter of fact I had the honor of having
the colonel work for me at that point in
time and then he went on to bigger and
better things
um right now I am the chair of the House
of the house yeah right while I'm on the
house I sat in the house for 10 years
five terms my first two years was on
this committee because at the time
speaker speaker chanler thought that me
a retired game Wen I had to be on the
fishing game committee well I had
fishing game again 30 years of fishing
game time to move on I was also a Selman
so after my first tenure here on fishing
game I was able to get on the municipal
and County government committee which I
enjoyed being a
selectman
uh I don't know where I was going with
that but anyway I have been on the on
the commission now about eight years uh
commissioner hodon who was in the corner
right there him and I came on the same
day we're the oldest setting setting
members of the commission
uh uh I I've been two years as chair of
the commission took a break commissioner
green took over then he he got sick of
that and then they got me back in the
next year and then I got sick of that
and now he's back in as chair so it's
it's it's a it's a situation that that
that can evolve into many different
things we govern our own we had recently
a commissioner that that
violated uh their oath and we had to
have a hearing with the Attorney
General's office and we recommended the
removal of that that commissioner and
that commissioner resigned before could
officially be removed by the government
Council so we do monitor our own it's
again not not a good thing to do but uh
it it's a right thing to do um I was
born and brought up in Pittsburgh
graduated from Pittsburgh High School uh
love the North country had a chance to
come down and be
Captain many years ago and no can't get
the North Country out of me I guess so
no I stayed right up there enjoyed being
up there and I enjoy uh representing the
the the people of Coos County that that
that they're real good people and we're
very very proud of the professionals
that have talked to you today they are
very dedicated individuals they don't
get real good pay but they they're very
dedicated individuals and and when they
come and speak to you uh that they're
they're talking right from the heart uh
so I appreciate being here I'm not going
to take any more of your time because I
know you got a whole bunch of bills to
do here today so thank you Mr chairman
for for allowing me to speak thank you
are there any
questions seeing none thank you so much
up good morning uh Mr chairman committee
members my name is Jim tatone I am the
uh Sea Coast commissioner I uh joined
the uh The Fish and Game Commission
April of
2023 my um main expertise comes in with
the Marine Resources I have heavily
involved in commercial fishing I
obtained my first uh State Lobster
license in
1965 and I also have a federal offshore
Lobster permit and I also have Federal
permits for for groundfish I've been
involved in lobster fishing I've been
involved in Gil netting longlining I've
crewed on um draggers so that's
basically the thrust of my uh expertise
um for um the SE commissioner um the
petition came up um and I had a
conversation with the former director
Scott Mason and he thought um talked to
me and asked if uh it'd be worthwhile
having a commercial fisherman on the uh
on the commission there were a lot of
challenges within the industry a lot of
regulations we're one of the commercial
fishing industry is one of the most
regulated Industries in this country and
with all the challenges and sustain
sustainability issues um in my
conversations with other fishermen they
thought it might be a good idea to have
some kind of representation within the
commission uh on on um this this um
Endeavor uh so that's when I became
that's when I became the commissioner
so uh
I do get a lot of calls from
constituents about different questions
about clamming about um fresh saltwater
fishing licenses size limits things of
that nature from Recreation from
recreational industry as well so
basically that's that's my story thank
you any
questions representative Khan you must
have a question he's your representative
on the
thank you Mr chairman I appreciate it uh
Mr ton if you please tell the committee
members you testified a couple of days
ago in another bill I don't want to
bring that bill but how big is the Gulf
of Maine compared to the whole ocean and
how much fishing the fisherman does in
Gulf of ocean to fulfill our demand the
Gulf of Maine uh represents just 10 10%
of the entire Atlantic seaboard but yet
the Gulf of Maine are responsible for
50% of all the seafood that's landed on
the Eastern Seaboard um there's close to
over a billion dollars worth of seafood
product that gets landed and if you put
the multiplier on that between the other
peripheral industries that involved
after the fish is landed that's going to
be in excess of $3 billion dollar of
economic U Prosperity that derived from
the commercial fishing industry so it's
it's pretty uh economically uh important
uh aspect of the uh of this entire
region thank
you any other questions all right seeing
none thank you so much for your time
up good morning Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Chris hodon I'm
mayor M County's commissioner I've
served on the commission since
2017 uh since joining the commission
I've been the commission's liaison to
the Heritage Wildlife Foundation the
principal nonprofit arm of the
department I've also served as the
commission's design on the rivers
management advisory committee uh since
2017 that's a multi- agency
multi-stakeholder uh organization that
advises a number of State agencies and
the legislature on issues related to our
riverine habitat uh I while I serve on
the that advisory committee as the
committee's designate uh we are
significantly supported by the
professional staff at the department and
in the Inland Fisheries Division and and
that effort effort as well um I have I
currently sit as the chair of the
sustainability and strategic planning
committee along with Commissioners stole
cavany uh
doosa and uh uh and then of course
commissioner green who sits ex official
on all of our committees um during my
time as a commissioner I've also sat on
the Hatchery committee which was a
special committee put together to assist
the department uh and the executive
branch in determining how we should move
forward with some of the issues that
Chief Timmons described and I I most
recently sat on the special committee
tasked with conducting the search for
our Uh current executive director uh
it's been my honor to serve with my
peers on the commission and the
outstanding and dedicated staff at the
department and I'd be happy to answer
any questions you may have thank you so
much representative Harvey do um in your
role as uh River's River advisory
committee do you ever work with the um
Connecticut River Valley Conservation
Commission so the uh that advisory
committee works most closely with the
local uh advisory committee so there are
19 I believe designated rivers in New
Hampshire uh there are several that are
tributaries of the um of the Connecticut
uh so yes in a global sense uh they they
thank you any yes representative love it
thank you Mr chair do you all as
Commissioners earn more than $100 a year
we we do not no we we serve as as
volunteers
yeah thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you sir
thank you much do we have any more
uh thank you Mr chair and uh nice to
meet the uh rest of you as as members of
this committee uh my name is I'm not a
real good public speaker so uh my name
is Bruce Temple I live in Claremont New
Hampshire and represent Sullivan County
on the fishing Game
Commission um I uh have been on since
20178 time frame and um have served on
various committees um within the uh uh
commission
itself uh my background is that of a
civil engineer and um somewhere along
the line many years ago I was fortunate
enough to become a licensed engineer in
multiple different states that I was
working at the
time a little bit of civil engineering
Consulting and then I moved into that of
uh heavy Highway construction
underground utility construction water
sewer pipe that sort of thing for about
25 years and then I moved into the
Public Works sector uh being the Public
Works director for City of Claremont and
when I retired I was the uh acting um
Public Works director for the city of
Lebanon and um that's pretty much it in
a nutshell um my background uh with
respect to uh the love of the outdoors
really started when I was young
um um Elementary School Middle School
Boy Scouts I learned a lot there of uh
outdoor activities and and um had an
uncle that was an active Hunter and uh
liked to go fishing so he always uh took
myself my brother along at the time and
uh even to this day I still remember
some of the uh the great times that we
we had then and do
today uh some of my other public um
service has been that of uh I've sat on
the uh school board for City of
Claremont
and um we won't go into the clima
lawsuit here but that's uh yeah that's a
different committee that's a different
committee rightly so uh but um uh I I've
also served as a uh three terms as a
city
counselor um been a member of the Upper
Valley Lake cipe Regional Planning
Commission in a former life and and now
I um represent Sullivan County thank you
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you for your time do
commission morning uh Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is uh
John cavany I'm uh the chesher county
representative to the New Hampshire
fishing Game Commission I am currently
in my fifth year as a commissioner um
I'm a native New Hampshire a Granite
State
grew up 20 mi north of here educated
locally a product of the University
system I say that with a smile because I
have a degree from the Thompson school
at UNH but I've also attended Plymouth
State and keing State so um uh I uh can
tell you that my experience with the New
Hampshire fishing Game Commission um has
been
um interesting for fulfilling and
educational in and of itself I will say
that um it's been said I'll repeat it
dedicated people okay who don't always
get recognition but they truly are in
the service of all of us um regarding
myself a little bit more um I'm a
lifetime license holder I have hunted
fished trapped skied
um hiked and camped from
Pittsburgh to the coast to the madok
region um outside of of my love for the
outdoors um and the only bad day in the
outdoors as if you're just not dressed
properly in my opinion um I have served
um others I'm a retired vice president
and Woodlands manager for a large
Northeastern Lumber manufacture fact 42
and A2 years in that um forestry has
been my gig um I have served on the
board of directors for the New Hampshire
Timberland Owners Association and still
serve on a committee for them um also
served as their president for two years
I also was on the board of directors and
served the northeastern loggers
Association um which is a group that
represents uh the Northeast
um and served as their president I am
also currently sitting on the forest
Advisory board that sits um at the will
of the state Forester and I have done
that long enough so that I currently sit
under Patrick Hackley who is the third
state Forester that I have had the
pleasure to to sit under um I serve on
three committees for the commission um
the legislative committee strategic
planning with Chris the governance
committee um and I think the only
commission meeting I ever missed was
post cardiac surgery okay so I've been
there and I will tell you that one of
the most interesting things that I was
asked when I went through the process of
interview if you will with executive
counsel and the governor's office and
others
um the governor's office asked me a
question and the question
was will you take phone calls and will
you return phone calls and I said yes I
will and I have so my contact
information is on the website or if you
have questions I'm more than happy to
try to answer
them thank you are there any
questions seeing none thank you for your
time today thank you
next
up good morning and thank you for having
us here today um my name is Patrick
mcgonagal and I'm the belnap county
commissioner um I also serve as the
chairman of the resources and
infrastructure
subcommittee um I'm a lifetime Hunter
and Fisher of fish in a lot of places
across the United States and some in
Canada um I got a Bachelor's degre
degree at St Lawrence University in
sports management and I have a project
management certificate degree from
UNH I currently work at Gunstock
Mountain Resort where I serve as a
facilities director of operations and
I've been there for 33 years in
different leadership
roles uh I truly enjoy working for um
fishing game I became a commissioner in
just about a year or so ago it actually
worked at I think Colonel Jordan's
office and the director's office called
my father who was a long-standing
commissioner on fishing game a number of
years ago and they said John do you know
anybody that would take that job and he
said hold on let me make a phone call uh
my father called me up and said this is
something you need to do and I said
absolutely my both my parents are long
serving um Volunteers in the community
both at the local and state level and I
kind of grow up in one of those things
where you never say no when someone
needs some some help so here I am I'm
truly enjoying it working with a great
group of Commissioners and doing some
great work um there any other questions
you may
have any questions I've got one before
we finish with the Commissioners uh
would you like to give an overview to
the committee on how uh you handle the
public hearings for uh changes to the
rules regarding hunting and such I don't
think we've heard anything yet about how
you have the the public hearings around
the state well the public hearings are
run by the department our job um is to
rep represent the county that we're in
and those views so as commissioner
cavany said I also will take every phone
call and I have in some of these public
hearings there's been a lot of phone
calls my cell phone is posted on the on
the Department's website and our job is
to take that feedback from anyone who
calls whether they're hunter fisherman
or or not from our County or even I've
gotten some from not our County um and
listen to what they said and take that
input back to the commission um when we
meet and discuss these topics thank you
any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
time today thank
up thank you Mr chair thank you
committee my name is AJ der rozer I
represent straford County and I'm the
vice chair of the commission I'm also
the chair of the public engagement
commission and also the chair of the
governance uh committee uh committees
not commissions and all that um in a
previous life I worked in La enforcement
in Boston where I served on the gang
intelligence unit um after that I worked
in the nightclub business where I
managed over 300 employees as a director
of operations for multiple facilities
and the last decade of my life I've
worked in hunting and fishing media
including owning um a bird hunting
publication which is actually the
largest in the country um I've also
worked on federal legislation stuff as
uh stuff like recovering America's
Wildlife act which I was involved in the
marketing team unfortunately we did not
get it passed um but we will never stop
trying um and I have been on the
questions ah representative DeVito can
you tell me your last name again and
also what's the name of the magazine
your bird magazine yes D Roa and project
upin
magazine thank you any other questions
no
up good morning chairman members of the
committee my name is David P I apologize
for a little bit of
lontis uh I am the newest commissioner
represented here there is one other that
came on at the same time as me Jean
Chandler um so I I've only been on a
commission since October um my
background is uh I'm I was a career
firefighter I 50 years as a
self-employed
electrician um and yeah I did that
through my firefighting because back
then firefighting wasn't a extremely
well-paying job um and when I retired
from firefighting I decided I'd do
something fun so I became a licensed guy
so a lot of the members of this
committee have seen me represent
presenting the guides Association in
front of this committee um you'll see
different faces now uh I'll I'll still
be actually I'll see you this afternoon
um but not as a commissioner but um so
I'm very interested in the in the in the
process I actually make up for the for
the the uh chair's lack of fishing I
spend between 100 and 150 days a year on
the water uh in some capacity so I make
up for those fish that you might not
um however I'm not the greatest hunter I
do hunt but I'm not the best um I could
help you with that thank you um so when
I got on the commission my intent was uh
I was very involved I was actually on
that hatri um advisory uh committee
commission um the governor set up and
very interested in maintaining that I
have between my wife and I we had 13
grandchildren and I'd really like to
maintain this so that they they enjoy
Sports thank you are there any
questions seeing
none do we have any more Commissioners
Ray green would you like to make one
yes I just wanted to answer two
questions that came up uh Mr chairman
one was
on um I present of your question on if
we get paid more than a St State Rep we
do not we do not the
only the only thing we're paid for is
our mileage we don't get plates we don't
get vehicle reg
registration um the commissioner that's
wearing a commission shirt he has to pay
for that
himself we we don't all we get is
mileage the other question was yours Mr
chairman on the public hearings we are
also as Commissioners required by law to
attend those hearings you know when they
have the um hearings to the public on
rule making that is done by fish and
game but we as Commissioners are
required to be there so we're also
hearing what the public is asking and I
just wanted to clear those up sir thank
you so much it is an important part of
what we have to deal with when we talk
about the rules and such yeah
anything further for any of them if not
thank you so much to the commission for
coming today and introducing yourselves
I guess 2 hours was just about perfect
um and uh thank you very much and as
chairman I want to thank you for having
us here very welcome thank you and uh we
will take five six minutes break because
uh we have a bill coming up at 11: but
if everybody's going out you might walk
right past Kyle Baker who is one of uh
our lobbyists you'll see frequently he
can feel free to introduce himself to
all of our members as they go
around
goes is
that
um
e
it's now after 11: we'll open up our
public
hearings and uh our first up will be
dealing with hb21 relative to the use of
air rifles for hunting game and I will
recognize representative James Spain uh
as a prime sponsor to um to start us
off thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee this bill has been uh second
two terms in the in the works um we had
an original bill that would open up the
idea last year um we retained that um
studied it over the summer and we
actually had
very uh very good field trip over to SIG
arms where the committee showed up the
commission showed up and the department
showed up and uh we proved the the uh
viability and
um and lethality of these larger boore
air rifles and uh determined that they
were appropriate for hunting big game so
this bill will expand the use of air
rifles from small game to large game
following certain
uh qualifications that we determined on
the Range were necessary to make them uh
work so
hp21 the language for that has come
directly through firsthand experience of
the committee the commission and the
department um it was drafted very
carefully and reviewed um we actually
went about this a different way than
they have in some other states it's
enacted in Maine and they allow it in
Maine but um it's not done appropriately
in Maine to what we've determined on the
Range in Maine they just simply say 30
caliber and above but what we found
firsthand while shooting into ballistic
gelatin and such is that um 30 caliber
just doesn't have the penetration
necessary and what we determined is it
doesn't matter what the caliber is is it
really matters how many how much kinetic
energy is generated at the muzzle so
it's a little different to
see
hunting put forward without a specific
caliber but I don't want anybody to be
shy about that because as you'll hear
from the Department when they testify on
it if they do um we very carefully
looked at the the penetration available
for the different calibers and the
different uh kinetic energy that was
generated at the muzzle for all of
those as such uh late breaking I had to
draft an amendment to this that we will
hear in exec during exec session if
uh we get a chance and so a copy of this
amendment I can pass around to everybody
so you can take this into account while
this
um the department decided at the last
minute that they they would like to have
the kinetic energy at the muzzle
determined not in statute where it's
stock in statute but actually in rules
that the the the department makes uh as
part of regular hunting rules so that
they could then separate out how much
kinetic energy is needed for the deer
hunting portion versus the moose or the
bear portion and they could increase
that kinetic energy required for those
larger game species and it also allows
them as technology continues to keep
Improv proving with these air rifles to
change that as needed and uh and further
refine the the uh kinetic energy uh the
foot pounds that's generated at the
muzzle of the gun and so with that I
will go ahead and end my testimony and
introduction uh and I'll take any
questions if you've got
them any questions for representative
Spain Miss representative mcferson yes
thank you um I am new to the committee I
am not a hunter so my question is um why
an air rifle so air rifles are new
technology uh they are being accepted in
multiple States across the US um they
are not your typical air rifle that you
think of when you think of a Daisy BB
gun you don't just pump the gun and
shoot it it doesn't have a CO2 cartridge
it has a large tank that's filled from
diving
tanks you can get about five shots out
of that tank and then you have to refill
it five shots is pretty convenient
because that's how many rounds we
usually let somebody take when they go
out deer hunting so essentially if you
think of the air rifle as a muzzle
loader that's using air instead of
powder that's what we're at and so one
of the guns that we shot was a 54
caliber wow perfectly acceptable for
taking down bar and moose as was proven
on the Range the penetration into the
gelatin block for that went right
through the back end and we're talking
about an 18inch deep gelatin
block the devastation of the wound
channel was amazing the hollow point
projectile that was used was uh fully
expanded and
um so anybody who was taking this out
hunting you'd be hunting essentially
like it was a muzzle loader but without
the powder and using an air tank
instead
followup followup who brought the bill
forward I mean who proposed it the one
last year was brought forward by
representative Cole and he will be
you representative
Harvey thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um so I I'm pleased
that you have an amendment that will
allow um
um the oh and I'm not using using the
right word the um kinetic energy to be
placed in rules but my question is
should this whole thing be placed in
rules should it be part of um fishing
games
rules procedure to allow hunting by air
rifles the department said they needed
this in statute first and then they
representative
Durkin thank you Mr chair um question
for you on the projectile is it
basically the same kind of projectile
that is fired out of a powed gun it's a
lead projectile and in the shape and
it representative KH thank you Mr
chairman representative thank you for
um representative here we see that we
giving the authority uh to the
commission to creating administrative
and hunting rules uh knowing the
technology is going so fast you
overnight maybe the someday maybe in
couple of years we're not going to need
any tanks you know we will have you know
better technology is it in anywhere in
this bill has that the commission will
have the power to change any any any
rules that needed you know for the
future technology once this base
legislation is in they can craft all the
rules they need around that and
especially now that we've also taken out
the kinetic energy at the muzzle they
can change that kinetic energy amount uh
as needed there's nothing in here that
defines what the gun looks like whether
it has a big tank or not so that kind of
innovation and Technology won't be
affected
um not terribly related to the bill but
just really curious so you stated that
you could get five rounds before you
needed to um basically reload uh from an
A a tank do you carry that tank with you
they did yes uh it's just like a diving
tank like you would wear if you're if
you're diving in the
ocean okay weird they didn't carry it in
the field with them but they if they
going out to a cabin to go hunting they
would bring that tank to the cabin um
and one of the things that's interesting
about these rifles is um you know you
know that as it gets colder pressure
changes and one of the things we had for
a question for them on the on the course
was well how do you handle a really cold
morning and the answers made me feel
kind of stupid for not thinking about it
but they said you fill it outside and
you leave the gun outside on the on the
porch and then it doesn't change
temperature if you fill it inside in the
war warm cabin and go out in the cold
you're going to have less pressure but
if you fill it outside and leave it
same representative
Durkin thank you Mr chair uh thank you
for taking my question um so has a five
shot Max on a tank we determined that
five shots gives you yes the and then
you're going to hit a warning on the on
the level of your uh air in the tank and
you're going to have to fill it up again
okay so followup yeah that was my
followup is there a sensor or something
that'll after that some of them have
gauges some of them you just have to
count because you know it's going to be
one representative tutor um we follow up
to this my original question was so
there's no mechanism on the weapon to
prevent the gun from firing when the
pressure drops below X so that some of
them did energy is going to be below
what we want yeah some of them had built
in Regulators as well that wouldn't
allow the the pressure to come out too
soft those are all aspects of the gun
manufacturer
though any other questions for
representative
much next up we would like to have uh
thank you Mr chair or vice chairman
roulette and members of the fishing game
so let's address a couple of the
questions I already heard out there five
shots you're in an air rifle you're
taking a shot you're loading around
you're taking a shot you do not have
time to take five shots when you're out
hunting if you're beyond three
shots you know you probably shouldn't be
hunting all
right we did an interim study on this um
he adjust he addressed the ballistics
gel which gave you the impact the
velocity of the
weapon to address two other things that
we tested on the Range we tested the
foot speed of the velocity of the
rounds so when you're targeting
something from far away you could take
three to five shots and you're not going
to drop down that menu shot will be in
the same
placement that's very important so
you're not
losing velocity when you're shooting
these these guns you're not losing the
pressure you're not losing the impact
the gun is going to perform the same
over the three to five
shots okay when you're out there hunting
that's important to
know um that was the air speeds test
that was the airdrop test we did the
ballistics test we determined that 30
caliber due to the foot-pound range of
200 foot-pounds was not sufficient to
take down an animal and make it ethical
that's why we gave the foot pounds to
the fishing game department to determine
what is
ethical so it'll be anything beyond a 30
caliber up to 45 caliber now these
weapons take down water
buffalo it's not a it's not a small
weapon it's very
questions representative
mcferson thank you um I may have missed
something these are not semi-automatic
they are not so you fire then load
correct similar to a muzzle loader
yes representative Stone well we're not
talking about air rifles are we yes air
pressure rifles 30 caliber 50 caliber up
to 54 caliber yeah are they legal enough
to take the de take a deer down they
will take down a water buffalo sir they
will okay yes at Le you know like you
said five shots I never
shidea as far as I know they're illegal
in Colorado and Maine and Colonel Jordan
can testify to any other states that
have legalized it when I when I hunt I
take him down one shot you know kill him
one shot if you have to food through
five times you shouldn't be in the woods
in the first place thank you sir that's
any other questions for representative
Cole seeing none thank you thank you
very
much are there any other uh attendees
who would like to test uh give testimony
on
this Mr berser on need a sorry I thought
a card had already been submitted I
apologize um yeah Dan buron chief of the
wildlife division for New Hampshire
fishing game um I'd like to thank
representative Spain for working with us
on this and U with offering this
amendment to allow us to set the you
know foot pounds of energy in rule um I
think comparing these to a muzzle loer
is is a good way to look at things um um
they are not your typical air rifle um
so if anyone has a picture of like you'd
said you know the Daisy Red Rider baby
gun in your head these are not what
those are um you can you can Google
these things and you can find videos
they are large they are very loud um
much louder than I think most people
would anticipate so when you take a shot
if you miss um by and large that animal
is is running um and that is the case
with with really all types of firearms
um so the department did have some
initial concerns you know when this was
when this was uh presented last last
year um again in large part because I
think it focused more on the caliber and
again with an air rifle um if you have a
large caliber but no air air pressure
behind that um the concern is is Humane
um take of an animal um that's always
the concern of the department when we're
looking at any of these new weapons um
we appreciate having this ability to do
this in Rule and I think the amendment
gives us the flexibility to do what we
need um I think a good example and and
Cory to this is um some of the changes
we've made in allowable shot for turkeys
so for example we didn't used to allow
410 um gauge shotguns for turkeys um
there was advancements in in the
ammunition where there's these um TSS
loads that are made of tungsten um so
the ballistics and those are very
similar to other shot that we allowed um
so we now allow those en roll um these
companies continue to innovate um they
find ways to increase ballistics of
different ammunitions and different
weapons um so that's why we like to have
this ability to be flexible and Rule and
change these things as they go um uh my
conversations with representativ Spain
we actually um in anticipation of of
this bill coming through we actually we
are in a season setting year right now
we're offering um we're putting forward
draft proposals for our Wildlife rules
that um focus on method and manner of
take and season length and timing um so
our our species biologists are looking
at ballistics and what other states do
um and they will have proposals that go
out to the public this year um for um
well likely the the restrictions for
these will probably be the the same for
deer and bear um typically ballistics
for something that you know would take
down a deer would be would be sufficient
for a bear as well um the big difference
will be Moose for certain um so we would
want something certainly more powerful
to take down an animal as large as a
moose um but again we appreciate the
flexibility to be able to do that in
rule um and I I think with that I can I
can answer any
questions representative KH thank you Mr
chairman Mr Bor uh what is step uh the
department is taking uh if if it is
becomes law on the uh for the law
enforcement agency this is not a toy
right this is a real gun correct and and
what step you're taking to educate our
law enforcement agency the town and
cities and everybody you know that uh
they know what is coming up in the
market so to educate local law
enforcement or the state law you know
all together everybody yeah so um so
it's these these weapons are currently
allowable for you know for anyone to to
shoot so they're you can own them you
can shoot them the the difference is
that you can now take game with them um
so likely local law enforcement are
already aware of the existence of these
the difference would be now you can just
now you can use them to hunt with but um
by and large um you know these would be
um these would be more on par with you
know shotguns and muzzle loaders which
are typically um these are typically the
types of firearms that that are allowed
in you know areas that are more
congested because again they're not
quite as powerful as high powerered
rifles so um you know some of the areas
um in your neck of the woods in the Sea
Coast and the southern portion of the
state have areas that are shotgun or
muzzle loader only due to safety concern
so these would be more along those lines
with representative
tutor uh thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question my I guess my
question is on enforcement I'm not sure
what the variation is from manufacturer
to manufacturer on the weapons and what
velocities they put out for a particular
caliber but how would you enforce the
energy number yeah I'll I'll defer to
The Colonel on that if he wants to come
up and answer that um it it will be a
little bit more difficult um because
again it's it's it's slightly different
from your typical firearm where there's
mass-produced ammunition that typically
all has you know similar ballistics um
that will be a little bit more of a
challenge although you know individ load
their own ammunition there's um um you
know we have a really good team of law
enforcement I'm assuming that there's
you know they're chronographs and things
like that there are devices that can
measure that um um it will be a bit of a
challenge but but
um most of these devices um have
information on what they're capable of
doing and I think my my assumption would
be and I'd defer to the colonel that
that it would largely um you would
largely fall back on whether or not
someone was out there with a weapon that
was incapable of meeting the
requirements um you know muzzle loaders
misfire things like that happen um I
don't foresee anyone intentionally
lowering the pressure on one of these
devices because um Hunters are concerned
with taking an ethical shot on on their
game and retrieving that animal for use
so um it would be more along the lines
of I think if an individual was in the
field with a weapon that was not capable
of of producing enough
energy representative harv
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question um my question it could you
just speak to um I assume we're going to
have to have another kind of license
then for these these air rifles and so
forth in addition to what's already out
there so could you just speak a little
bit about um you know that licensing
process the seasons of take and you know
all of that kind of stuff yeah so we we
wouldn't necessarily need uh I think our
initial thought would be that this would
be an allowable weapon within our
existing firearm
season down the road we could consider
if we wanted its own season the problem
is um so deer is an example so with deer
we're kind of near the northern limit of
deer range um we particularly with the
more mild Winters we've had we have a
very healthy deer population so we we
are we are able to allow a lot of
opportunity for folks um that said you
know we're not Pennsylvania we're not
Connecticut um so we have restricted
time frames there's a lot of different
um user groups that that like to take
advantage so we have archery we have we
have muzzle loer we have firearms but
even within those there are different
individuals that are always kind of
looking for you know their own kind of
time in the woods Alone um it's
difficult to accommodate all those um so
so what we tend to do is we allow
certain weapons in in different existing
Seasons because you just can't parse it
all out um so this would likely be an
allowable weapon during our existing
firearm season that you could use with
your um with your regular um hunting
license F followup followup thank you um
thank you um I guess to what I was
trying to get at
was you would have to purchase I'm
assuming a different kind of um hunting
license you know you you purchase a
hunting license for muzzle loaders and
so forth so would you purchase a hunting
license that allows you to hunt with air
rifles so would this be another uh
Revenue source for fishing game um you
you could set up a separate license I
think our initial thought would be that
we wouldn't do that this would just be a
an allowable weapon within an existing
season so for example um you know you
can use
um you could use a an a bow and arrow
during the firearm season you can use a
crossbow during the firearm season um
this would now allow the for the use of
an air rifle during the during the
firearm season you can use a you can use
a bow and arrow during the firearm
season without having to buy an archery
license you're using your existing
regular hunting license in the tag
associated with it um if you want to
hunt during the archery season the
difference there is that allows you
extended an extended period of time to
hunt um but if an individual was fine
with the length of the firearm season
and wanted to and chose to use a bow and
arrow during the firearm season they
could they could do that I see okay
thank
you any other
questions representative
Stone what is the what is the the foot
pound the Velocity in the uh of the of
the round the Grain in the grain bullet
yeah um I don't know offand so our our
species biologists are kind of looking
into what they what what seems most
appropriate um and foot pounds yeah so
for foot pounds what we've what we seen
so far is that it tends to be about 400
foot PBS for deer and bear and about 600
foot PBS for a moose basically the same
foot pound of 9 mm or 40 40 Spence of
Western yes that's about what it is I
was a scout sniper in the Marine Corps
and uh I just want to make sure they can
take it down they shoot it once should
it don't go down you know just to stand
there and keep on shooting it's I don't
I don't go for that no absolutely and
and you know we teach that in our hunter
Ed courses um you know the the most
important thing is taking an ethical
shot on that animal um you know you make
sure of what your target is that you can
take a good shot that you're not going
to have concerns about missing that you
recover that animal um we'll likely um I
would assume we'll likely put out some
educational material about these about
these weapons being a new weapon um to
the public um we may um and like I'd
have to talk to our public affairs
division but I would foresee us um
folding some information into our hunter
Ed courses about these these weapons as
well um but yes absolutely and and those
those um those viewpoints are already
taught in our hunter Ed Course what
about age
group kids you want these things the age
followup if you like to have a followup
question you have to yeah recognize by
the chair to have a follow-up question
all right
follow up
yeah so you're you're asking whether or
not youth would be able to a great age
age limit the age limit on these weap
these you know young teenagers and yeah
it would be the same as all of our other
weapons all right yeah so it doesn't
matter okay y I thank you
yep representative
K thank you Mr chairman um my question I
am myself I'm I'm a gun right person
person and I like to see that my you
know fellow citizens in my state New
Hamshire they have the Equal Rights like
mine and everybody else it's too many
lines to read and you know for me to
understand but for the record I want to
ask you all these things are written is
there
anywhere
um stop the gun rights for any manner or
shape um so I I'm kind of going off the
amended version um that's that's what
the department is support of I I don't
see anything within the amended version
of the bill that that would reduce gun
rights for anyone um if anything this is
allowing an additional um I mean it's
not a firearm under the definition but
um this is an allowance of an additional
weapon to to hunt with so I I don't see
anything in there thank
you any other
questions thank you Mr Bon thank you
very
much um
Colonel
Jordan orig good morning again
originally I wasn't going to testify uh
Dan was going to do that but because of
the law enforcement questions I wanted
to so the question regarding um first of
all I want to tell you that we were we
were not in favor of this in the
beginning until we went to the range and
actually saw these demonstrated to us
we're confident uh that these guys have
done their homework and we're we're not
producing something that's going to
wound animals uh and lose them that's
number one number two I think currently
the technology is fairly expensive uh
and I think I think the prime sponsor
would agree someone who uses one of
these guns is going to have some going
to have to it's going to require some
knowledge about how to use it working
with compressed air and the like so I'm
not concerned that it's going to go wide
to the public in the first year it'll
just offer an opportunity for another
method there are advantages to it that I
see and and I'm basing that on on what I
get for calls so using it down in a in a
um you know a more um populated area
like we have in the southern part of the
state I think it'd be better than a
rifle uh it will have less noise it will
be while they are dangerous I don't
think they're they're as dangerous as
discharging a 30 yard six within the
city limits are conquered these would be
safer for that so I think that would be
an advantage um um And in regards U
representative Harvey for the license so
the licenses you point out muzzle loader
bow and arrow anything that offers
additional time to hunt a certain
species we normally get a license and
we're and so to start with this we're
going to put it out during the regular
deer season I will say this that the uh
the writers of this bill representative
Spain representative Cole were pretty
careful about how they did this and we
had a long discussion regarding Pitman
Robert's money so Pitman Robert's money
comes into the department based on
Firearms tax and and ammunition these
would not be would not meet that
standard so they were concerned that we
were losing uh possib possibly losing
income so I believe they put the in the
bill that we would have the authority
the department would have the authority
if we saw fit to uh write or or create a
rule that would require a special air
rifle tag if we Cho chose to do that we
our plan is to kind of roll us out
slowly to educate people uh like we do
any of these things to make sure that
they're on board with how to use it and
then we'll review how many take take
partake in it so the important thing to
remember is if we by giving us the and
this was a I want to thank the chairman
for doing this giving us the opportunity
to do this in rule also provides the
general public with a couple of bites at
the Apple to come in and learn about
this and and give us their opinion
because to get anything in rule you got
to have public hearings and so that's
going to give the The Hunting Community
uh and any everybody for that matter an
opportunity to come in to see what we're
doing and why we're doing it so I think
it's it's even a better way than doing
it through um legislation it's going to
give them a more a better opportunity as
far as enforcement goes I don't see it
being a whole I will have to educate
some of my staff because I was educated
when I went to the range um but the guns
are very telling when you look at them
and hold them uh The Operators will be
able to tell us what they shooting with
very much like we're doing now we have
limitations on 22s we have certain
limitations on calibers um some of the
straight wall cartridge laws that have
passed you know it it requires us to
take that stuff in hand and look at it
but but I I don't anticipate great
challenges to that um again I think that
first year would a first year or so
would be a year of Education much like
our cameras have been uh we've spent
more time educating people than pinching
them um because a lot of people
violating the law they just don't
understand it so we work to try and make
them understand it and then we work to
get the criminals later so the people
that are intent on doing it so I I want
to say I think it was well thought out I
appreciate their patience we were not
always easy to deal with um and and I
appreciate them taking us to the range
so we could actually shoot these things
and see it I'm much more confident on
their ability after watching it and
talking with the manufacturers uh and I
and I certainly appreciate
representative Spain and representative
willingness to let us do it in rule that
will help us control it that will help
us adjust for any problems that we might
see and it'll give the public a better
chance to voice their opinion so you
were a pretty good shot with it too yeah
it we did it we did all right there I
will tell you the other thing that was a
bit amazing to me representative Harvey
is I was under the impression multiple
shots I was concerned about a second
shot you lose pressure I personally shot
it three times at a very low loss of
pressure and a very U minimal um
variation on the Target no my I think my
muzzle loader would do the same so I
think if people are mindful of that like
you have muzzle Loos I think they're
accurate representative
Harvey thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question yes ma'am so
um we heard testimony from the sponsor
that it seems to be manufacturers are
not
I don't want to say consistent but there
there's differences in different kinds
of air rifles some
allow regulation and some you have to
count how many times you've shot and so
forth since there's differences in the
manufacturing of these air rifles is
that going to cause any problem in uh
law enforcement in the beginning it'll
be a challenge to make sure that we're
all Ed we're going to be educated on
them and I have a plan for that to get
them educated um I don't but mu loaders
do that now so there's a big difference
between an inline muzzle loader a break
open muzzle loader and a and a Thompson
Center a regular muzzle loader so that
was a bit of a learning curve for some
of the some of the some of my officers
that didn't hunt prior to getting this
job so we spent time with them so they
could see that and once I think once we
get them educated I I don't I don't
anticipate a great deal of problems
frankly I might be surprised but I don't
know how many people will use it because
it is a bit cumbersome with the tank I
think as technology advances um more
people become ready to use it but I but
I think it'll it'll I don't see a danger
to the wildlife that's important to me
personally I don't see a danger to that
I don't see a safety danger I think they
could be shot and handled safely with
some education uh and I think we'll be
able I'm confident we'll be able to
enforce it so I think it's been well
thought out um and I I think we're ready
for that followup please followup um and
and you just said and I hadn't thought
of that um Pitman Roberts won't apply to
this because no right but you feel that
there's something in this bill that will
allow fishing game to um collect POS at
some point to possibly collect money
from from the tanks itself I guess I I
didn't see no I I I misspoke tag so what
what represent we talked about that at
the range that day that this would uh
exempt the income from Pitman Roberts
and he put in the bill he gave us the
Authority in the bill to write special
roles to create a tag a a air tag was my
understanding if you look at page two
line 29 we added the executive director
May further adopt rules pursuant to RSA
541a to create issue and cell tag
specifically for hunting with an air
tag any other
questions thank you very much thank you
Jord
with no other uh people for Testimony
I will now open the hearing on HB 61
creating a committee to study laws
harvesting I do not have any
cards
the chair recognizes rep anber the prime
sponsor of the bill to introduce it all
right thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is Aiden
anenberg I represent straford 7 which is
the city of
Rochester I'm here to introduce House
Bill 61 which is uh forming a study
committee to exp um to um look at the
laws um regarding commercial harvesting
of oysters in New Hampshire um and the
important part in there in the duties in
the bill is um expanding purpose of
expanding the industry um so this is
actually the fastest growing um
shellfish product and fishery in the
state um started about 10 years ago
where the commercial Harvest really
started growing and now it's it's it's
we're over like a
th% um over like previous harvests and
things so um you know there are a number
of issues related to um oyster
harvesting right now and that um there's
95 Acres U between Little Bay Great Bay
and Hampton Harbor that are actively um
licensed for oyster farming um UNH did a
study a number of years ago um that
there was potentially up to 400 Acres so
we're um available to be um leas um for
o commercial oyster um farming so we are
a little under a quarter of our Max
Capacity there and we need to make sure
that the the you know the state is doing
its part to create the environment by
which you know the industry can expand
up to potentially that 400 acres and
that we are looking at all sort of
relevant um factors in terms of that
while that industry grows that we're
able to one you know test the oysters to
bring them to Market safely uh provide
access especially in Little Bay um where
it's difficult for the the farmers to
get into the bay um um you know a number
of different issues um enforcement of
poaching
regulations um you know when we have
these um when when the oysters are
growing underwater as they are now um
there's not a lot of um enforcement the
people looking at the actual water to
make sure people aren't going out there
and opening opening these things and and
taking them out of there so um there's a
huge range of issues with with um oyster
farming that we can look at um that's
kind of what I'm seeking to do here um
kind of comprehensively look at all of
these different issues solicit testimony
um from the farming from the farmers
themselves the department the public um
there there has been some talk um of
property rights issues with um abutters
to the waterways um if they were to use
um top water gear um so in terms of like
the the view um so there there's a
number of issues and really what we want
to do is look at all of these different
issues take testimony on them and then
come back to um the committee with
immediate
recommendations um sort of intermediate
so like years out any type of
Appropriations that would need to be
made um we' be looking at uh making
those recommendations so it' be
immediate um sort of intermediate and
it's kind of
long-term uh recommendations that we
could make to you folks so we can do the
the difficult work of looking into these
issues and then so when we come back to
you you know your next year and in your
previous and U following by anms that
you you can have some confidence that
we've looked into these issues um
solicited the testimony and then we're
giving you accurate recommendations as
to how to move forward so that's what I
would be asking you today is that um you
that you would support this um so that
we can look into helping the the oyster
farmers of New Hampshire um and as the
industry grows that we're kind of
covering all of our
bases thank you are there any questions
represent Smith thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question Who
currently sets the season and area of
harvest right
now so that that would be the
department official game department okay
follow up follow up so it's done
currently through the rules process for
them well I imagine it would be through
that yes follow up follow up if there's
such a need for this why haven't they
explored expanding it
currently so I'm I'm not so much well
the that's just the 95 Acres that I was
talking about is what's currently um
licensed in New Hampshire there like I
said it UNH has said that there is
potential potential for up to 400 Acres
so I I couldn't speak to why we haven't
got to that point but I'll say like the
industry has been growing we have 12
commercial Farmers now um and the the
any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
committee chair will now call Melissa
clf hand them down and and they'll get
turn on your
mic thank you so much thank you for
giving me a few moments to express my
support for House Bill 61 my name is
Melissa paly I am the Great Bay
piscatqua Water keeper with conservation
law Foundation clf is a member supported
environmental advocacy organization um
that supports um Environmental
Protections in communities throughout
New England and and in New
Hampshire um I know a few of you are
from the Sea Coast region and probably
have a great appreciation for how
beautiful the waterways are um in the
coastal part of New Hampshire there's
some really nice paintings here if you
need a reminder but uh the bottom line
is that all is not well below the
surface as much as our our region is
quite beautiful um we've had Decades of
growth in our communities increases in
the amount of sewage and septic systems
and land use changes that flush storm
water into our waterways with every
rain um many of our communities are
working very hard under new federal
permits and others uh other mechanisms
to reduce the pollution um in invest in
improved
infrastructure uh better treat
Wastewater and storm water but progress
is slow and
expensive meanwhile one of Nature's most
effective clean water machines is hiding
underwater um in the Great Bay
Estuary um we we think that a couple of
decades ago in the early 90s we had as
many as 25 million
oysters um in the Great Bay each oyster
is capable of filtering 30 to 50 gallons
of water every single day removing
pollutants using algae in the water as a
source of food for growth and when we
had 25 million oysters in the Great Bay
estor um we believe that those organisms
could filter the entire volume of water
in the entire estro every four days it's
kind of a miracle you couldn't build a
treatment system if you had billions of
dollars that do what oysters do for
free um so I'm a big proponent of all
kinds of measures that are going to
increase the population of oysters to
rebuild back to the 25 million that we
had we lost
95% of our natural oysters in the
Estuary in the 90s due to several
diseases so that coupled with the loss
of underwater Meadows of um seagrass are
what really have put the Great Bay
Estuary into a state of
decline but one of the bright lights
that we have seen in the past 10 years
as we just heard is the growth of the
oyster aquaculture industry in Little
Bay um from just 10 years ago when we
had a few pioneering uh Farmers we now
have nearly 20 we've seen a tenfold
increase in the number of oysters
harvested in the um little Bay Region
and while some of those Farms are still
solo operators others have Farm managers
and additional staff they provide jobs
they provide healthy food they support
our local economy and they really are
clean water machines so oysters really
are a triple win um and we should really
be doing everything we can to increase
this important industry in New Hampshire
just two weeks ago The Nature
Conservancy uh and the Great Bay
National estaran research Reserve had a
meeting um of about 30 or 40 people
including Fish and Game Representatives
UNH researchers clean uh clean water
Advocates uh and many oyster Farmers to
discuss the constraints and opportun
ities um to increasing the oyster
aquaculture industry and there were many
topics raised as again noted um problems
with the current permitting process uh
constraints on access points for people
that need to be out on the water every
day to tend their farms uh more
education uh to help people especially
uh AB buding land owners to understand
the terrific value of aquaculture to
increasing the health um of our
waterways and the many economic benefits
that this industry provides so these are
the many reasons why I'm really pleased
to see um this bill come forward and I
hope that you'll support uh HB 61 um and
as we move ahead in the years to come
we'll see this this industry um really
continue to grow uh I'd be happy to take
any questions and thank you for giving a
questions okay seeing none thank you so
today the chair will now call Meredith
Conservancy thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee I am Meredith
Hatfield and I'm with the nature
conservancy and we have beening working
in New Hampshire for over 60 years on a
broad range of environmental issues um
and as you see uh in my letter and
attachment um that does include um
working with Farmers to support uh to
support uh aquaculture of oysters um we
agree with much of what um the Great Bay
Water keeper just testified to so I
won't be repetitive um I do have a
colleague who is an expert in this area
and and runs the programs that we have
she was not able to be with us today but
um she would be certainly available to
the study committee if you proceed with
this bill so that we could share our
experience um our resources um and
collect information that's helpful to
the study committee if it were to be put
into place and I'd be happy to take any
questions thank you are there any
questions seeing none thank you for your
time
today the chair will call what appears
to be our last speaker uh Steven
Jesso
jenso uh New Hampshire shellfish Farmers
initiative thank you so much for your
time today I am Steven jenso here
representing the oyster farmers of New
Hampshire the shellfish Farmers
initiative and I'm here to express our
full support for hp61 to establish the
committee to study the laws around
oyster harvesting and lure I again fully
support all the testimony received
previously and won't repeat everything
to put a few additional numbers on some
of the testimony that we've seen uh our
oyster farms in 2023 provided a $5.5
million benefit to our economy in terms
of Agriculture coupled with 4.4 million
in passive benefits ecologically that is
a $9.9 million benefit to the state of
New Hampshire in 2023 alone accomplished
under our existing framework and that
represents a 1, 153% increase increase
in the past decade we have done a lot
with what we've done now and every
single oyster of that commercial Harvest
comes from aquaculture we do not have
Wild Harvest in the state of New
Hampshire those oyster farms using 95
acres are largely located in the little
Bay in the Great Bay Estuary with one
operating in Hampton and in fact those
aquaculture not only do those Farms
provide the filtering mechanisms but
they are actively going towards
reinstating the wild farms and the wild
oyster fields that provide additional
ecological benefits to the state and in
2021 about 30% of the oysters harvested
for aquaculture were in turn sold to
benefit those ecological projects it is
a very self- sustaining and
self-benefiting partnership between the
oyster Farmers between fish and game
between the many conserv efforts going
on for a very treasured Great Bay
Estuary we have the full support of the
farmers are willing to provide any
benefits possible and any information
needed for the committee full full
support on our
end thank you are there any questions
representative
Khan thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question um we have the
commission you know they look all you
know this is their jurisdiction that
they make rules and they look after this
why we need another commission to you
know create another commission to
oversee and funding you know is working
right now the way I see it the way
they're you know in my knowledge is it's
working it is it is working within the
current framework but the current
framework is not set up to support and
prioritize our oyster and shellfish
aquaculture in the state this is a
rapidly growing industry that has been
working within rules and regulations
that are not built around oyster
aquaculture and oyster harvesting uh we
think it would be beneficial to take
some time to look at this industry
specifically where it is being supported
by the current laws where we running
into some difficulties in terms of
managing and maintaining the Farms um I
don't want to dive into specific issues
but there are even things in terms of
the way legislation is written where it
is not necessarily causing an issue um
but some things like using the term
lease instead of rental things like that
cause Insurance impacts for the farmers
there are many Ripple effects from how
they operate their farms and how we
permit them to operate that we think
would be really beneficial for the
future of the industry to step back and
say we support this we would like to see
your continued healthy expansion and we
want to see what we can do to encourage
that
thank you representative
Harvey I I think I misheard but did you
say that uh some of the
results and harvest from these um oyster
farms supports wild
oyster yeah so there are a number of
restoration projects you did there are a
number of restoration projects being
done by our wonderful Partners who have
spoken behind us to restore natural
oyster reefs and there is a wonderful
interplay between an oyster Aquaculture
farm and a natural Reef where not only
are we raising oysters ones that are not
fit for commercial sale can be in turn
replanted and help grow our natural
reefs but the very existence side by
side even the shells that are used from
oysters that are sold are then turned
and used to grow reefs and provide
natural beds for oysters to grow on
thank you you're welcome any other
questions I have one please um
most of the things that currently have
provide a framework under which the
oyster aquaculture is being run are
rules and um so my question is why would
we need a study committee to look at
this from a legislative standpoint have
you actually approached the commission
and the department to talk about rules
changes um I will say I'm actually
fairly new being involved so I have not
personally been involved but I am aware
that the oyster Farmers have been this
initiative has been running since 2020
have formed close Partnerships with Fish
and Game have been working on things um
but we see this as a wonderful
opportunity to really get that step
forward and operate as a group to make
recommendations versus individual
Farmers proposing adjustments to rules
thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
time thank you I do not have any other
cards is there anybody else from the
audience who wants to speak that hasn't
seeing none I will close the hearing on
HB
61 committee we have a break now uh on
paper until 1:00 when we hear our next
bill would anybody like to uh move into
Bill let's do that
I'm going to open executive session on
hb21 FN I'll let my clerk get prepared
for
that um everybody has a copy of that
Amendment so just so you know uh a
positive dispensation on the bill will
allow us to put the amendment on and
amended and are we
ready all right so opening the exec
FN
and Mike uh representative ulette offers
OTP and it has been seconded by
representative Murphy we are now open
for
discussion do we have any questions or
discussion from the
committee representative Harvey uh thank
you and when I first read the bill I was
not in favor of it um I felt that it was
something that should go through rules
um but with the amendment I can support
this thank you very much representative
Fox thank you chairman for you as a
hunter um why would you choose to use an
air rifle to hunt as opposed to
traditional for me personally um it
would be the same as sometimes I want to
use my muzzle loader versus regular
rifle but I can also see the utility
aspect for some someone who lives in a
high density area such as the Sea Coast
where we do have a large deer population
we are having trouble getting enough
people out hunting them to decrease the
population and this is another
alternative besides a bow that would
allow them to do so thank
you any other comments representative
Jacobs um uh are you familiar at all
with why other states haven't approved
these
um guns because they're so new is my
understanding ument Jordan do you have
are
states if you'd like to take the mic you
can explain uh just a little bit of that
since we have an expert here I'll let
him answer our
question so I just check with my my
executive director is here by the way uh
director simic so I just asked her
Washington State uh allowed for it and I
believe there are three I I may be wrong
on this but I believe there were three
western states that allow that after
kind of the same kind of consideration
we've done um I don't know of any in New
England Maine that's right excuse me
Maine does yes I'd forgotten that so yes
there are there are a number of states
that have done
it any other comments
questions okay the clerk will call the
role on oh actually I'm going to amend
sorry I offer now forward Amendment uh
let me read the number I need my glasses
for that Amendment
73h the amendment to 211 FN which puts
the
muzzle kinetic energy into rules and
removes the hardcoded from the
bill um I've moved the amendment does
somebody want to second
that rep Smith has seconded the
amendment
we're open for discussion on the
amendment does anybody have any
discussion on the
amendment seeing none the clerk may call
amendment
chairman chairman
yes Vice
chairman
yes
Repcon yes rep
tutor rep Murphy yes
yes rep
Durkin
yes clerk votes yes rep Harvey yes rep
Fox yes rep lit yes rep
Jacobs yes rep oor yes rep Pearson yes
yes and rep I apologize rep Murphy Smith
um 15 15 to zero we now can move to the
that
chairman
I Vice
chairman yes rep conon yes rep
Smith yes rep
tutor yes rep Murphy yes rep Durkin yes
clerk votes yes rep Harvey yes rep Fox
yes rep lit yes rep Jacobs yes rep
oor yes rep Pearson yes rep Stone
yes that's 15 yeses zero NOS any
objection to consent I was just going to
say
that no objection seen we'll be putting
this on the consent
calendar uh I will need
a um committee report report from
repet is there's nobody else to write
one so that's fine um and we will now
get to hear from our brand new director
before we go to lunch do do you point of
order do you need a a report when it's
on consent just curious you still need
one in case it gets pulled from consent
oh and oh by the way I'm closing the ex
exec session on 21 there we
go good afternoon I'm Stephanie welcome
to the committee well thank you I'm
Stephanie simic I'm the executive
director for fish and game and I'm
thrilled to be in New Hampshire although
I'm not a New Hampshire native I'm
quickly becoming a a transplant that
will probably never leave I'm enjoying
the state very much and enjoying uh
meeting all of you I'm sorry I haven't
had a chance to go around and introduce
myself uh more formally but um it's
times are fast right now everything is
happening really fast so I hope I get a
little bit more time with each of you um
I know you heard from my staff this
morning uh I'm very lucky fortunate to
be working with this group of people
it's a committed group of people and I
say that from the lowest levels of our
staffing tiers to the highest levels of
our commission every single person has
very very dedicated to this program and
to this agency which by the way I've
been boasting we're 160 years old we
should be proud of that um and they're
very dedicated to ensuring that we have
Fish and Wildlife Resources for our
future Generations um I'm happy to
answer any questions that you may have I
didn't have a formal presentation I just
wanted to get a chance to say hello and
to thank you all for this opportunity
and thank you for the support that
you've given us through the years and I
hope we can continue a strong
relationship with this
committee thank you so much are there
any
questions I have one yes is the cell
phone number for the executive director
handed down from one executive director
to another on a company phone or do you
have one new
I believe I may have Scott's number but
I don't know just wondering if I hit
executive director in my phone am I
calling you now or am I going to get
Scott on a beach somewhere well I hope
you're calling
me I'll make sure you get my number for
sure I'll double check before I
call and uh thank you I would like to
just add for for your all the
information regarding the oyster farming
it's a complex situation it's not just
fishing game that is involved in that
Dees with water quality that's a primary
uh partner in there so you may know that
I just wanted to make sure that it was
stated here so that everybody was aware
and representative Jacobs there are
several States it's it's probably around
13 to 15 states that are using air guns
or air bows in their hunting for large
gain you're
welcome representative Khan thank you Mr
chairman I do not know that if we're
going to get the um um the commissioner
is going to be present on the Wester
Farm thing but I do have a question
about the Western you know so just
simple questions we have the commission
commission is working fine we all you
know we see in every aspect of the way
do we need another committee to you know
do
anything we need a legislation to find
another committee I honestly I I can't
speak to that to be honest with you sir
I haven't been here long enough to know
what the issues may be I'm hearing from
one group but I am also hearing from
other groups that everything seems to be
working fine we work through our
commission um for our rules and where we
stand on policy and legislation so I
would defer to them on where they may
see we need this stand um we usually as
a staff bring those points to them and
they will uh defer on them and they will
let us know where they support or not
support you're
welcome has anybody else have any
questions for our new director oh yes oh
for
me well we thank you for coming today
and making the time I hope every went
well over in the executive council
chambers and everything earlier very
schedule R Fox what's your question for
a clarification on
hp61 um if we were to vote in that
committee uh there's no fiscal impact
for the state is it just the time of the
people who are serving it doesn't have a
fiscal note and it's usually um just the
people who have to get stuck on the
committee for the
summertime uh however times many times
they decide to meet and and whatnot it's
uh it's a statutory committee so it
would it would end up meeting after our
legislative session ends but before the
fall comes in and usually there's a
deadline in the bill about when a report
needs to be generated and and so it
usually entails someone from the Senate
who never shows up and uh two members
from the house that usually do show up
um and and then whatever other members
of the public are involved D in it thank
you let's go to lunch everybody should
be back here by let's say 10 minutes of
one so that we're ready for the next
bill so the Dems are going to caucus
very briefly in 403 uh right now okay
you could even use this room if you
wanted to we're all leaving is that okay
thank
e
1:00 I'm now opening the public hearing
for HB 404 relative to information on
the hike safe
card and the chair recognizes
representative Darby Prime sponsor of
the
Bill thank you chairman Spain honorable
members of the uh fishing game and
Marine Resources committee I do uh wish
that I was on this committee again this
year um for the record my name is
representative will Darby I um represent
Hillsboro District 11 the welcome people
of national award
8 bit of background um the voluntary
hike safe card was introduced in 2015 to
support the fishing game uh search and
rescue efforts it raises between1 and
$300,000 per year which is significant
help uh to fishing game which is facing
a multi-million dollar budget deficit by
2027 the intent of this bill is to
increase uh the to build sorry to build
interest in the hike safe card to basic
basically access new markets get more
people interested in it um but
ultimately sell more hike safe
cards the um over the summer um chairman
Spain and I were on a study committee um
for the fish and game department um uh
looking at funding and Partnerships uh
looking at funding and Partnerships for
the fish and game department um and they
recommended the recommendations coming
out of that were to increase uh sorry
partner with other organizations to
increase sales of heke hike safe cards
that was one of the
recommendations the problem that this
bill attempts to solve is that the
definition of family as currently used
by the hike safe card is uh increasingly
disconnected with um modern New
Hampshire families cohabitation has uh
in uh dramatically increased across the
country um partners are having children
with no intention of marriage um
partners are having children before
they're married partners are having
children
um and uh uh choosing to live um
together in familiar relationships one
in four unmarried adults um in the
country uh 30 to 39 are uh cohabiting
and New Hampshire is above average in
these
statistics the current hike safe card
limits um the legal uh family to the
legal spouse uh children stepchild and
guardianships um from a personal
perspective um my daughter just had our
first first uh grandchild last year and
she made a conscious decision to um have
a child the year before she got married
because of timing family uh timing
reasons but she definitely um feels part
of a family with her
fiance my ex-wife uh is uh cohabited
with a partner um for many many years
that my daughters considered to be their
stepfather for all intents and purposes
similar with my to my wife's uh
ex-husband and uh his partner
there's a need to um to increase
Outreach to new groups um to increase uh
this for the hike safe card um and often
young uh younger uh PE the younger
Generations have a different mo more
modern definition of family Tyler Ray uh
uh um testified at the um that study
committee that I mentioned um and he
recom he recommended targeting a younger
a audience and developing uh strategic
Partnerships um and uh uh organizations
may I believe that organizations may not
promote the card uh if they don't feel
like the family the definition of family
accurately matches their
membership I have discussed this with
fif fishing game and in particular uh
Colonel Jordan who I believe is going to
testify shortly um about the uh about
this bill before and he recommended a
Amendment um that I have and I'd like to
pass out if that's possible um after my
testimony um that adds some clarifying
language with respect to domestic
Partners um it um the domestic partner
is used in one statement uh one place in
existing statute but it's not defined
this helps to provide that definition it
is also defined in administrative rule
60214 in conclusion um you the New
Hampshire hike safe card provides a
great way for the community um to
support fishing game while staying safe
on the trails sales can be increased by
building new Partnerships um to uh
Target a a larger audience and this bill
helps to align language uh that increase
uh that will help to increase the
revenue uh that uh ultimately will help
allow fishing game to
have rely Less on General funds and be
more self-funded thank you very much uh
Happy of course to answer any
questions thank you are there any
questions representative
wette uh thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um I I uh
question I had is is there any concern
that actually might lose some Revenue uh
for partners that are both buying cards
now as and and going to one that there
might be any loss of Revenue
well I I I might defer that um to uh
Colonel Jordan to see if if they're
concerned from my own personal
perspective I think that people would
actually be um I think that people don't
understand the definition perhaps of um
family and so they might be buying one
thinking that they're covered when
they're not especially long-term
Partnerships um only to be surprised if
they actually encountered you know some
kind of horrific situation um and you
know there's been some
um one of the things I thought of for
example when uh when putting this bill
together was you know could people try
to take advantage of it like you got two
um two people living together um they
share in an apartment and they're like
hey we live together we're domestic
Partners I I personally am not worried
about that because I think that it would
be um bit embarrassing for somebody to
say yeah I'm trying to save 15 bucks so
that I can and I'm saying that my buddy
and I are domestic Partners I think
that'd be embarrassing so no I'm I'm not
personally worried about it thank you
for the question thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
time
absolutely the chair now calls Noah
himself uh good morning uh thank you Mr
chairman uh members of the committee uh
my name is Noah tersi uh I live in
Nashville w 8 represented by
representative Darby and I'm here today
in support of
hb44 uh I believe personally that it's
important for me to contribute to the
stewardship of New Hampshire's natural
resources and the outdoor spaces that I
enjoy using uh and I don't hunt or fish
so the hik safe program gives me the
opportunity to do that um while I always
strive to be prepared for my time
Outdoors as we've seen in the news this
week even careful and experienced hikers
can find themselves in trouble
and my hike safe card gives me and my
wife some additional peace of mind when
we're on the trails uh I first
discovered the language in the statute
that this bill seeks to change two years
ago when I went to purchase a h a h safe
card for me and my then fiance and I
discovered we weren't eligible for the
family card despite living together and
being only a couple months away from our
wedding day that got me thinking about
all the other families that would
describe themselves as families and yet
be excluded from the family hike safe
card because of the limits P placed on
the program in the statute marriage is
not the only thing that defines a family
and so I believe that this change in
eligibility for the family hike safe
card uh is a positive one I think this
change will encourage more families to
participate in the hik safe program by
making purchasing a card easier and more
accessible uh since they'll only have to
purchase one card they can ensure
everyone is covered um instead of having
to buy multiple cards or potentially
having people go uncovered by the
program with more families participating
who are not currently uh that means more
support for the hard work of Fish and
Game officers and Personnel around New
Hampshire who make our outdoor spaces
safe for everyone I support this bill
because it will make it easier for
people to support our state's natural
resources while they safely enjoy the
beautiful trails and outdoor spaces that
make the state a special place and
because of that I asked the committee to
advance this bill to the Full House with
a recommendation of ought to pass uh and
I guess I'll say it sounds like a
clarifying amendment is something that I
would also be amendable to and I have a
an additional copy of my testimony if
the clerk would like it if you want to
pass it around to the clerk she can make
sure it goes in the file thank you thank
you are there any questions for
Jordan good
afternoon Mr chairman and members of the
committee so representative Darby and I
want to thank both representative Darby
and the chairman for their support over
the summer meeting with us over these
Financial uh challenges that we Face
there was some good ideas that came out
of that and I'm hopeful that things will
change uh moving forward this was one of
them that uh representative Darby
reached out to me about uh changing the
over so if you remember a few years ago
we moved to um we we amended the
original statute of having a single card
for a person or a $35 card for a family
we moved to cover adult children who did
not
had not left the home that were
emotionally challenged and under under
guardianship would they be covered and
we added that to the family Bill other
than that we've not made any changes to
this um moving forward I didn't oppose
this at all I thought it was a good idea
it will representative olette it may
make a difference on income U but I got
to tell you you know we look at these
very carefully so we've never build I've
never build a person that has a hike
safe card even though the allows me to
do that if they are ridiculously
Reckless and they still have a hike safe
card they can still face a bill uh the
idea of the card was to get everybody to
contribute to the system so we've never
been put in that position where we've
had to do that I've had call some Scout
Masters that want to take 10 Boy Scouts
up and his question was do I have to buy
cards for all 10 of my Scouts and I've
indicated you do not if you have a card
you will be covered so we're pretty
liberal on this anyway uh for the most
part so this change I thought was good
the only issue I had with his change and
that's why you have the amendment before
you is I wanted some sort of formal uh
reference or description of what a
domestic partner was so we wouldn't have
two people hiking together saying well
I've got a hike safe card but you don't
and so today you'll be my domestic
partner so he put in the bill that it
means someone who shares the same
address as the purchaser and then the
Justice rule uh attorney general's rule
that he referred to describes that
pretty accurately so I can defend that
in court if that becomes an issue um so
I would urge you to pass it we I didn't
tell you this at the beginning I
apologize the commission reviewed this
after our recommendation we voted to
support this
change thank you any questions
representative
Harvey why didn't you raise the price of
it it's a cheap card the idea was yeah
and I get that a lot in fact I I get
question you know why don't you make it
$100 card the idea of it the thing that
that two things I looked at in in 20 15
I was a little skeptical that it would
even work to be honest um and I was
pleasantly surprised it's only grown in
in every year since then so I'm a little
lery of raising it where it's a
voluntary fee I think you could hit a
point where people won't buy it um and
so you know now you can have a if you
have a hunting license a fishing license
any one of these an OHV registered a
boat registered a snow machine
registered you've already contributed
this you don't need a hike safe what I'm
finding is a lot of those very people
are also buying a hike safe card so
you're adding if we increase that price
it would probably add to that so I'm a
little leery at doing that I think and
and then people will say to me why can't
I print the card how come I don't get a
fancy card because I wanted every dollar
of this to go into search and rescue so
I wanted to keep the administrative cost
to a minimum so we don't make a card
they just go online and do it and and
that was the whole goal of it it hit
over $300,000 this past year which was
tremendous so it's been pretty good but
we you know we could increase it I just
worry and and the other thing that
happens is there are constantly people
trying to attach things to it because it
has been a success so they're trying to
hook other things to it I fight like a
cage dog because it's one program that's
worked well let's not mess it up let's
leave it where it is and and it's making
good money for us I'm using it every
year to buy equipment at the end of the
year I bought a cruiser with it last
year uh that we would have never been
able to purchase so it's it's been a big
help and I I do agree with repres even
this old dinosaur agrees with
representative Darby kids aren't getting
married as much um there are a lot of
people living together that don't share
a marriage license and and that's not
something I ever thought about so it' be
nice to have something to cover
that representative
ulette thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question yes sir have
just as we're sitting here thinking it's
it's nice to see what a success the hike
stfe card is has been yes um I know as
snowmobile racing in the country the
biggest organization is the
international snowmobile racing
association yes when you become a member
you pay $25 but there's an insurance
policy that goes along with it yep have
you looked at putting an insurance
policy I have and so we met several
years ago we met with several insurance
companies and they want no part of it
they don't want to insure it because
they feel that the um I'm trying to
think of the term you use the liability
attached to it would be huge cuz it
happens he asked me for the numbers of
how many of these things we do when I
gave him that that ended our meet that
ended our conversation so we tried you
know just over the and you know because
you've been a part of it some of it but
over the years I've tried uh tax on
hiking gear I've tried water a tax on
the local water Distillery I've tried
all these different insurances to cover
all these different things and Licensing
them but then I'd have to have uh
officers hiking the mountains to make
sure they have a they have a hiking
license and and then you struggle with
well what's hiking and what's walking
and and you know when when is it fair to
charge so this was really the resolve of
that um this hike safe card and it and
it I think it's reached a a good medium
um I think it's probably time to look at
maybe increasing it a little bit but I'm
a little cautious to do it just because
it's going so well I think if we hit a
plateau then I might mess with it a
little bit to see if we can get it up a
little higher than that but um and you
know that the I never ceases to amaze me
how many people in tune with this as I
said to you these two poor women were in
in 40 below or 50 below weather up there
freezing to death standing together and
had been for three hours when my team
arrived there the first things they said
were we have hike safe cards both of us
so it's it's really um in the front of
people's minds which is great so that's
really
good any other
questions representative Pearson how
many search and rescues do you Bill in
yeah in yeah so I get asked that a lot I
get calls by the way we get calls from
all over the country because people
think this is a good thing and they
asked me questions like um if it's okay
Mr chairman they asked me questions like
does this prevent um people from calling
because that was one of the naysayers
this is going to prevent people from
calling if you start billing I argued
it's not going to if people think
they're going to die they're going to
call for an ambulance they don't ask
when they're at a car accident how much
is the ambulance ride going to cost me
they get to the hospital then they worry
about it that's what happens to us so it
doesn't it doesn't create worse
situations we don't do it a lot I use it
as an advertising tool you'll see me use
it in the press a lot because I I don't
have a way to measure this but I know
for a fact it prevents problems because
they are worried that they could
potentially face a bill so I think it
causes people to think about a little
bit so we do 180 missions I I look at
this about every 10 years average it out
we do about 180 missions a year on
average some years a little higher this
year it's going to be a little higher
some years a little bit lower we have 14
drowning missions almost to the to the
number every year 12 to 14 um I Bild 11
9 to 11 rescues in a year I don't do we
don't do it a lot it's got to be pretty
egregious Behavior we collect about 60%
of the ones that we Bill uh I make deals
with a lot of people I'm not above that
you know when you've got a $40,000
rescue that's a lot of money so people
will say listen I have five Grand would
you take that we've done that I've taken
donations when I've sent a bill they
wanted to donate to the Cause We've let
the bill go um so we're we're really
pretty flexible on that I've got an
administrative assistant who's become a
collection agent much to her dismay but
it but uh so we don't do a lot of it but
it's a it's a tool that keeps people
buying cards more importantly for me
keeps them I hope hiking safely so that
we don't have to deal with it so it
promotes all of that so I think it's a
great tool for that yes
sir any other questions that's a good
question seeing none thank you for your
time today and is there anybody in the
audience who wanted to testify and
hadn't handed in a
card seeing no one I will now close the
hb44 does the committee want to move
404 all right let's do
404 representative Murphy moves out to
pass seconded by representative
Khan It's Now open for
discussion is any anybody have anything
to contribute to the discussion on the
underlying bill before we take up the
amendment not seeing any would somebody
like to offer the amendment for the
gentleman that brought it I make a
motion for the amendment do we have a
second thank you both we're on the
amendment discussion now does anybody
have any questions or discussion on the
amendment as it's
written I'm going to oh sorry I'm going
to support it but I wish it had the
price had been raised and I'm just
saying that for the
minutes well the price is not in
statute any other discussion yes
sir I I support it but I think it they
should go to a small small hike it would
help them
out little bit of a hike you know you
don't got to go lots of people have said
that yeah I think I think go up a little
bit everybody else does every business
out there
does everybody said that right now I I
say hi all right not a big one but you
know some help him out a lot better yep
any other discussion representative Khan
thank you Mr chairman uh question for
you Mr chairman that U now that we heard
from the my fellow um representative
that it should be price should be a
little bit High a commission can do that
you know you know this knowledge that we
are sending this the commission can take
take that position in future in future
thank you thank you
Mr okay seeing no more discussion I'll
amendment chairman Spain yes Vice
chairman
olette yes representative
con yes representative Smith yes
representative Tudor yes representative
Murphy yes representative jerkin yes
repres uh clerk votes yes representative
Harvey
yes representative Fox yes
representative lit yes representative
Jacobs yes representative oor yes
representative Pearson yes
yes did I miss anybody no 15
to okay the amendment passes 15 we're on
the original bill as
otpa any discussion as amended seeing
none let's have the clerk call the
role chairman Spain yes Vice chairman
ulette yes representative con yes
representative Smith yes representative
Tudor yes representative Murphy yes
representative jurkin yes clerk votes
yes representative Harvey yes
representative Fox yes representative it
yes representative Jacobs yes
representative oor yes representative
Pearson yes representative Stone yes
it's 15
yeses move
consent Mo consent been moved anybody
have any objections to consent seeing
calendar we now have a 7-minute break
before the introduction of our next bill
at
1:30 and I will let the committee know
that I will be downstairs introducing
another bill at 130 so the vice chair
will actually open the hearing on
647 and one of my co-sponsors will do
61 so not in the short amount of time
when I got to go
downstairs if I didn't have to go
this
it's
one
for
e
at as it is 1:30 we will commence our
hearing on HB uh 647 and we'll start
KH good afternoon Mr chairman good
afternoon uh Comm member of this
committee my name is Abul Khan I
represent cook Rockingham District
30 uh I'm here to introduce HB 647 f
relative to the fee for a newborn
lifetime hunting and fishing
license and Mr chairman I'm reading from
the uh Bill methodology this bill
replaces 300 fee for a lifetime
combination hunting and fishing license
for residents under the age of one year
newborn license with a Authority for the
executive director to establish the uh
the fee through administrative Ru making
the department assumes the fee for such
a license will increase significantly
when determined actually as required by
the by the
bill the department also assumed that
such an increase will serve the uh serve
to reduce the number of such license
sold annually ultimately the department
cannot estimate what impact the
increased license fee will have on
Revenue though the expectation is that
bill will result in a net
increase for information informational
purpose in 2023 the department sold
1,092 newborn license at
$34.50 each which includes the required
habited sarch charge and agent fee for a
total of 332
$332,500
4 in total for comparison a lifetime
license for the residents one year to 16
year is
uh
1,564
80 I can answer any question if any U
have any questions for representative
KH representative Harvey thank you Mr
chair so um I thought I was following
and then I got confused um happens a lot
so are you saying that the director will
set the fees there there might be a
different fee scheduled for a newborn
that's 0o to one and then a another fee
for someone that's 1 to 16 is that what
you're
saying uh representative I was not ready
for this question would you mind if um a
department uh
anybody so yes I'm I'm sorry I didn't do
a card I'll do a card for you
um for the record my name is Kevin
Jordan I'm the colonel at n fishing game
um and the commission voted to support
this bill this change so yes I believe
my understanding is that she would set a
different fee in rule for the infant
license and everything above an infant
would start at age 16 so these are when
they figure a lifetime license they're
done on actuary table depending on your
age they estimate how many years you'll
live and your license is adjusted
accordingly the price of it um for me
it'd be $10 but for a young person it
would be uh hundreds of dollars and so
what's happening is we're selling a lot
of these which is a good thing um except
in time down the road this is going to
cost us significantly we've lost a lot
of or will lose a lot of Revenue so we
wanted the ability to adjust this um so
yes to answer your question she would
she would have one price for the B for
the infants under a year and she would
start with uh anything above a year my
reading of it my understanding of it uh
would start on the table at age
16 she would so I could go in for my
5-year-old I could buy him or her a
lifetime license but I would pay
according the same as if my child was 16
yeah
yes thank you and my license was only
$50 too yeah mine is mine was a good
deal
so represent Fox thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question yes sir
any idea what the fee would be for a
newborn for this and whether anybody
would actually take advantage of it once
it's raised so she didn't no one has
communicated to me certainly what that
would be um I do think they would take
advantage of it because it's wildly
popular now and I don't think it's
popular because of the price I think
it's popular because people want to do
something for their child so I see
grandparents doing it for their
grandchildren I did it for all of mine
um so I I don't think it'll change that
but the income I think it'll be higher
than
$300 um but I don't think it'll be where
it is at 16 I think it's 16 and I'm just
shooting from the hip here I want to say
it's like $15 or
$1,800 so at 16 it starts at that so uh
it'll be significantly higher thank you
yes
sir any other
questions thank you sir I'll I'll get a
thank and with that we'll close the
I just got B do we want to exec uh 61 or
647 that you just heard bolt
bolt which would you like to start with
Repcon 61
please I will open the exact session on
hp61
I have
a
motion of itl from rep Smith and a
discussion rep Harvey um I think we
heard from a number of people this
morning that um testified that um this
is a a a great idea um it's a
complicated idea something that's more
complicated than can be taken in rules
and um it would be beneficial to the um
um the agricultural industry but also to
our water and so forth so um I can't
support the
itl representative
wette thank you um the um testimon was
very interesting but the two problems I
had with it was first of all and both
was there was nobody from fishing game
or Dees here to uh support it give
testimony uh go against it I I think
it's got some great ideas but I don't
think it's ready to
proceed representative Khan Mr chairman
thank you uh U byair you know echoed
what I was feeling also at the same time
I'm not very big to put a commission top
of we already have a commission that who
is working every
day thank
you representative
Fox I would be inclined to vote against
the itl simply because uh it's a it's a
small committee I'm not going to cost us
anything to get it done and um you know
the environmental benefit and the fact
that uh oysters and beer for dinner
every day of the year make me feel fine
so absolutely thank
else seeing no further discussion I will
ask the clerk to call the role well I'll
first if it if this bill passes it will
be people that voted for it that could
put on the committee I'm not going to
ask someone who was opposed to it to
serve on the committee in the middle of
their summertime for something that they
didn't feel was worthy I just want to
let that that I think is fair
representative Harvey I I just went back
through my notes and um although we may
not have had um somebody from fishing
game speak formally when the bill was
introduced certainly the commissioner
did speak of the commissioner of fishing
game did speak in favor of the bill well
she said she couldn't really speak on
that because she's too new and doesn't
know the
situation was what she actually said
okay the clerk may now call the
role
chman sorry
yes Vice chairman
ulette yes representative con m m Mr
chairman I'm sorry to interrupt but I'm
I'm just have to understand that we
voting for itl thank you thank you very
yes representative Smith yes
representative tutor yes representative
Murphy yes representative jkin yes clerk
votes yes representative Harvey
no representative Fox no representative
LoveIt no representative Jacobs no
Representative oor no representative
yes we have 10 yes and five
NOS okay this will not be on consent
um will there be a min minity report yes
there will be and that will you
representative
Harvey uh by Thursday morning I would
appreciate that they want me to ask for
it by the end of the day but we're going
to have a long day here so I'm going to
say by Thurs by Yeah by tomorrow morning
give you all night to write
it I'll stay up late okay and uh the
report for the majority will
closing the exec session on hp61 we
still have time I will open the exec
session
by representative tutor and a second by
representative
discussion does anybody have any
discussion to to put onto this
one seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the
role chairman Spain
yes by chairman ulette yes
representative con yes representative
Smith yes representative tutor yes
representative merphy yes representative
jkin yes clerk votes yes representative
Harvey yes representative Fox yes
representative lit yes representative
Jacobs yes representative oor yes
representative Pearson yes
representative Stone yes 15 yeses
any objection to
consent seeing none this will go on the
consent
calendar close the ex close the exec
yeah we've still got a long enough time
let's just recess till 2 o'clock we've
got a 2 o'clock bill so everybody please
be back here by then but feel free to go
get
great
e
members of the
committee
this is a housekeeping Bill requested by
the
department uh they have
Revisited the uh levels of Their fines
on several areas and they asked that we
put
in some uh legislation to allow them to
change those and so I did
um we will have an amendment to this but
it's was ruled non gerain it's another
housekeeping thing to be added to the
one housekeeping bill but because it
wasn't the specific areas of fines and
restitution it was ruled that we had to
have a public hearing on that Amendment
alone so that'll be happening next week
um but for the rest of the bill we're
here to hear it today and uh so
essentially the bill increases the
restitution for the illegal taking or
possession of certain animals and to
make that restitution mandatory it
allows for an increased hunting license
suspension for a third violation of a
fish and game law or regulation and it
establishes a Class A misdemeanor
penalty for a third offense violation of
fishing game offenses that carry a
license suspension
penalty uh I don't know about the rest
of you but uh I was kind of disconcerted
when I saw that we had a repeated
habitual
um poacher that was arrested and uh they
lost their license for a year I was like
the
heck so fishing game Revisited a lot of
their Penal penties and stuff that
hadn't been looked at in a very very
very long time and under a new economy
with new uh needs to deter some of the
repeat offenders they asked for some of
these changes to be made and so I will
leave most of the discussion onto the
specifics up to the members of the
department who are here to talk about
them and if you've got any questions I
would probably tell you that they're
me representative Harvey uh thank you Mr
chair and I'll ask the question you
anyway Mr chair and if you don't like it
then you can defer it okay um I think
this is great and um I'm I'm All forward
the only uh issue that I had was the uh
fine for
Fisher uh Fisher and Bobcat otter and
fox definitely we've seen a a very large
decline in the number of fer and fox in
our uh state so I'd like that F to be
well that wouldn't be up to me that's
something that I think that the uh the
department has a good handle and the
biologist of the department decided in
discussion what they thought a fine
elevation should be and certainly we can
all discuss it here but uh it's been put
in the bill at 500 because they thought
that was appropriate at the time so um
if they can if they are convinced to
raise it elseways we can put an
Spain thank
you which one
is so this this is the one next will be
Colonel
Jordan good afternoon represent derin
again my name is uh Kevin Jordan and I'm
the colonel at New Hampshire fishing
game our commission actually brought
this bill so this was one commissioner
um it was and he is going to speak I
think following me but basically uh he
asked for this bill and I worked
together with him to create the update
so a couple things this bill does is we
left it originally it had said if you
look on line seven on page two it said
may we struck that to put shall because
I had judges that um quite literally
felt that the fine and the loss of
license was enough they didn't need to
be charged with restitution so this and
judges are good at following the Law
whatever law you create they follow it
to the letter so that was the idea of
striking May and making it shall so they
will pay this every time um and then we
went down through these these
restitution amounts had not changed in a
number of years um and we originally
talked about changing fines
um and there's there's a couple of
school couple of things I want to make
you aware of on fines first of all to do
fines it would require a number of bills
to be filed um and so there's a lot of
room for that to go
astray uh two to to be honest with you
when you deal with people in the woods
or people fishing it's a different I was
a police officer before I came here and
it's a different um got to say this
carefully it's a different
clientele so the the people that I deal
with today say to me regularly I will
pay anything anything you want I don't
want to lose my hunting license I don't
want to lose my firearm I don't want to
I don't want to go under suspension I
don't care about the fine amounts and
there is that thought that they'll pay
anything and I think financially a lot
of those folks are in a better position
in their lifetime they've got rifles and
Equipment they're in a better economic
position to pay those higher fines so I
talked to commissioner uh green out of
doing the fines and I said let's do the
restitution that's something that the
the state would benefit from this money
could come back in we could put it back
into Wildlife or in activities to
promote habitats and build these um
things back up so we felt that
restitution was a better fit we also
felt making a mandatory would take away
any discretion from the judge um I think
they'd follow it where it says shell the
second part of this is we do have if you
if someone is so any hunting violation
carries with it I'll use hunting as an
example any hunting violation carries
with it one-ear automatic loss of
license they have the opportunity or
ability to appeal that so we hear from
the court that Kevin Jordan paid his
fine on November 19th um that is sent to
the administrative my Administrative
Assistant law enforcement and she sends
out a letter to these individuals saying
effective on November 19th because of
your court conviction your hunting
license will be suspended until November
19th of next year and so then we but we
also in that same letter offer an
opportunity for a license hearing so
they Comm into the license hearing I
have the officer who wrote the summons
uh myself and the executive director sit
and we give them an opportunity to
present a case once they've been
convicted they can present ideas or
arguments to the executive director why
that suspension period should
change uh they they don't get to debate
whether they're innocent or guilty
because they've been convicted that that
part is over but they can come in and
say things like we have a I have a clean
record I didn't understand the rule um I
didn't think I was violating the law
those kinds of things and the executive
director takes recommendations from my
officer I kind of sit heard on that so
we don't go astray and I'm very careful
to make sure that we're consistent as
much as we can be every scenario is
different but you still have to be
consistent you can't suspend one Hunter
for 12 months for shooting a deer in a
close season and the next guy who comes
in the next hunter that comes in that
did the exact same thing but because
he's a nice guy we're going to give him
a month suspension you got to stay
consistent because these people will do
right to knows to find out what you're
doing so I I take great pride in the
fact that we are consistent I will also
tell you that we will negotiate a
reduced sentence more often than not if
someone takes the time to come to the
hearing and they present a reasonable
argument and we can determine by talking
to them they're truly uh sorry and we've
done our job in law enforcement in spite
of what my young officers think is not
to punish people that's the Court's job
our job is to change their behavior so
if I can look at a defendant and decide
well he's learned this person has
learned not going to commit this offense
again we can then reduce that sentence
when this runs a foul is when you do
that or if you don't do that and someone
goes under suspension and then they go
back out within the next year and they
do it again the second time now they get
under statute they get an enhanced
penalty under current law so if you
convi con if you con uh commit two
hunting violations within a 5-year
period you will lose your license for 3
years but we don't have anything beyond
that so and we have a few that
continually commit offenses um and so
another thing we did in this bill was we
talked about making a habitual offender
status to address that very thing um as
I said we don't have a lot of it but the
ones that you do have you want to you I
want to hit them harder because they
don't either don't care and they're not
going to change their behavior um or
they haven't learned anything and they
we really need to get their attention so
this turns into an habitual offender
status which makes it a misdemeanor for
them to do that it also would open the
opportunity for jail now I think we all
know I can't get drug dealers locked up
today it's just not the way it works
anymore it's sad but that's the truth so
I don't know how many of these people
we'd put in jail but we certainly a
misdemeanor offense gives them a
criminal record uh gives us the ability
to find them more
um it it brings it to a whole new level
and I'm hopeful that that would be a
deterrent against future um activities
so we don't have as I said good the good
news is we don't have a lot of that but
we do have some and I want to have a
tool uh to be able to address it all of
the
hearing um rights would still exist they
will always give them the opportunity to
come in and have a hearing before the
director the Attorney General wants us
to do that and we've always done that so
we would continue it in this but there
would be an enhanced penalty for
that that's all I
have representative
Khan thank you Mr chairman thank you con
Jordan for taking my question uh
question number
one is it possible that uh Fish and Game
Commission and fish and game department
both supporting this Bill yes I and I
apologize I didn't say that yes a
commissioner actually brought brought it
but the commission voted unanimously to
support it and we work together on it
followup followup thank you Mr chairman
uh Colonel Jordan please tell us that uh
the violations you know that how big is
the problem for your department to face
the violation at The Hunting violations
that we just like to know that if it is
more in 2024 then 2023 if you give us
little history so it's interesting
because we the dinosaurs over there we
did things a little differently when we
were in the field we made a lot of cases
I made a lot of cases I I liked
investigations and I we did it kind of
the oldfashioned way uh by sitting in
fields at night and waiting for people
to shoot out the windows or light up
deer light up Fields what I'm finding
with this new generation is their their
savviness with technology is much
greater than mine and they are making
cases that we would never these guys
don't like to admit it but I will admit
it they're making cases we never would
have made and they're doing through cell
phone technology they're doing it with
search warrants searching cell phones
because the good thing about criminals
today they can't help themselves they
take pictures and they text their
buddies and they post this stuff and God
bless them that's how they get caught
and so I've got guys now trained men and
women trained to go into cell phones
after securing a search warrant and
seizing those phones based on probable
cause to go into those cell phones and
we're finding we're making cases that
are three and four years old old so
there this year we were up uh we we also
decided to start publicizing some of
those cases a little more this year so
we we weren't doing that and that's a d
that can be a double-edged sword when
you do that um to post when people
commit these offenses but we've been
encouraged by my commission to start
doing that so we've done it kind of on a
careful basis I've done it with more of
the serious offenders cuz remember
people make mistakes you know on a
occasion it's a true mistake and so I
don't want to punish people in their
reputation and cost them their job
because they made a mistake however
people that are hardcore poachers and we
have them uh that are killing animals I
can think of a big case we made this
year with a bunch of Corrections
Officers that were lieutenants
repeatedly shooting animals at night and
doing things in the prison that we
uncovered and so they ended up losing
their jobs it was a huge case that is a
case that we did publicize because I
think that should out there that they no
you know they didn't get a pass they
were handled uh severely because their
damage to the wildlife was
significant um so I would I I'm not
ready to say it's on the increase I do
think we're making more of them because
I think I have a smarter Field Force
frankly I think they're sharper at this
than we were and they're doing a better
job so we're they're they're hungry for
it and they're making a lot of cases
this will will be a great tool for them
uh to to to punish people hold them
accountable so again it's not our job to
punish people I think officers lose
sight of that it's our job to change the
behavior and uh and if you can do that
with a warning that's the better way to
do it but if you can't then you issue a
summons and and we let the court punish
them thank you representative
Harvey so let me ask the question I
asked the chairman only I'll ask it yes
ma'am in your words yes um if we raised
the um amount for Fisher and fox
especially to a thousand instead of 500
because those animals are on the decline
in the state of New Hampshire would that
change
Behavior I don't know that I could say
it would change behavior um I think you
could make an argument that they're
they're because what we get into is
arguing the value of animals and
everybody has a different opinion there
are I can find people that'll tell you a
wild turkeyy is worth twice what you're
asking or a deer is worth a lot more um
as long as it doesn't derail the
progress of the bill I I would like to
get the bill through I think it's
important to get it through um I don't
believe I don't I would not have any
objection to that I have not run it by
my commission but I would not have an
objection to that their idea was to pick
these these amounts up to make them more
modern um so that's my answer to that
thank you thank you representative
Durkin thank you Mr chair and thank you
Colonel for yes sir question um I was
looking through this amendment this uh
uh some of your introductions here on
the restitution on the second page there
yes uh regarding the payment to the
court um if they are guilty contempt
such person shall not be negligible to
purchase any uh license issued by the
fishing game until all assets are paid
in full yes would it be a good idea to
maybe add you know penalty of interest
if they're not paid in a timely manner
or I don't think we can charge interest
I would be all in favor of that but I
well the penalty is the so what they
would be uh one thing this bill doesn't
do because it already exis in law they
would go into into court default because
this would be a court order so when you
failed to pay a court order or you
failed to abide by a court order you go
into default and they charge a penalty
they charge that fee so they would have
to pay I believe $100 the motor
vehicle because they would lose their
driver's license they have to pay $50 to
us on top of any and all Court fines and
restitutions so they get charged that
through the court I don't think we can
do that but the courts can I I will tell
you another interesting thing coming out
of the Dark Ages with our our licensing
and internet for years you could buy a
if you went under suspension in New
Hampshire for hunting you could go to
Walmart if they didn't know who you were
you could buy a hunting license and our
system allowed them to do it was
ridiculous I scream for years that that
should change and in order to do that we
had to revamp our licensing system
online Kathy uh through many meetings
with Kathy lebani that you who you met
this morning we were able to do that uh
just recently that one online and those
poor girls in my office are taking call
after call after call people back in the
90s that went under suspension default
and have been buying licenses right
along and now they can't and so on
January 1st we we were inundated with
calls because people wanted to buy
fishing licenses go out and fish and the
system wouldn't let them do it anymore
so that was a good move kind of gave you
an idea how many people were out they
still doing it so I think we've
help any other questions for Colonel
Jordan thank you very much thank you I
do yeah Colonel yes ma' sir I like your
proposal here a th000 per animal a th000
for deer beer moose up a th000 but wild
rabbit muskrat and gra girl $10 to 50 I
$50 is ain't enough it should be a
100 also with the wild turkey 500 it's
not like we got 100,000 wild turkey in
the
state it should be a thousand on
turkey and Fisher bobcat and OT and fo a
thousand and beaver and mink and that's
a thousand you're not going anybody can
pay the 50 or 200 but you start the
Thousand Mark you're going to think
again you know I think that's what Tri I
I I think it bills great but you got to
get off it up it I think it's too low on
some of them 50 bucks they ain't nothing
right they thr 50 bucks they way in in
an hour representa Stone you have a
question we'll take a question but uh uh
uh Colonel Jordan here is for Testimony
questions testimony but we're not here
good thank you sir any other questions
thank you thank you Jordan our next um
testimony will come from commissioner
Ray
commissioner um I'm commissioner Ray
green I am the Commissioner of hillsb
County I'm also chairman of the fishing
game and Marine Resources committee um I
was the one who brought this follow I am
the one who is responsible for this and
I'll give keep it very brief this came
about because of one day there was a
news article in a paper in Milford about
a family that had gone out and was
caught for poaching deer and this was
their numerous times of poaching the
deer and I received over a period of
three days of that newspaper
article 48 phone calls from constituents
saying something has to be done about
this out of those phone calls that came
I think I received six phone calls from
their own family
members out of the 148 phone calls from
the people that I spoke to at least 100
did said it's time for jail for these
people I went to fishing game obviously
as a commissioner and I says it's time
we have to relook at the
poaching as you can see on the fines
that used to be there I believe my
comment to the colonel was the poaching
fines are like going to wends and
looking at their dollar
say come down hot on somebody the reason
of doing this was we were trying to do
it as a
deterrent against poaching we understand
there are people that will make a
mistake so it wasn't a matter of the
first time
somebody ran into a poaching situation
that they're going off to jail we were
going after the repeat offenders that
are constantly out there
poaching animals regardless of what
happens when it came down to the fines
our poaching was beginning to look kind
of like on the couple of years back on
the snowb bill fine get a $25 fine
people were looking to get it to say
they got a trophy of a $25
fine I when I first went to the colonel
my findes that I had recommended a lot
higher
what like you representative a you're
saying the problem that we had with that
which I understand is if we came in with
the fines especially matching some
states out west we felt that
it it had hurt the bill is what we
thought we wanted the bill that came in
here that was clean a bill that was
understandable this bill was
based kind of on the understanding if
you think of the DWI law in the state if
you go out and do it three times in a
row you become an habitual offender you
do it again you're going to
jail originally fishing game could only
do penalties up until I believe it was
four years the driver's license is
seven you know the state can go back
seven years on your driver's license why
can't fishing game go back seven years
on game violations so that's why the
seven years came in there I personally
went out and spoke to judges on this on
where the language in there has been
changed to instead of a judge May to
where the judge
shall and that situation was when a
judge is handing out violations and
penalties in the courtroom he likes to
he or she likes to be the nice
person oh I'll charge your fine but I'll
wave the penalty or I'll lower the fine
I'll drop the
penalty this way here the judge has
taken off the hook they agree with it if
that law says I have to they have
to as far as going and changing the
fines when I sat down with the colonel
and the major I think we came up with I
would have had to change 87 different
rsas
if I were to walk in here with a bill
that says change 87 rsas I bet you to go
LTL nobody's going to take the time to
look at it there was a lot of thought in
this we spent over a year on this to
make it fair and use it as a deterrent
towards
poaching I know you've all have seen the
Articles lately in papers this also
covers Us throughout the whole state and
it also goes into with our marine life
where when you just saw the recent thing
on the amount of stripers that were
taken over
limit so there was a lot of thought lot
of work that went into this we're trying
to beef Fair would I want to see those
finds higher oh yes
yes but I don't want to take the chance
of ruining what I call a good bill
no questions for our
commissioner thank you very much thank
time that'll close that closes our
FN representative Harvey so uh you can
let me know if I'm out of line I don't
know if this is the right time but I I
would like to bring in an amendment that
does raise that line to $1,000 your
timing is impeccable oh I was just about
to announce to the committee that if
they have any personal opinions on
something that should change in the bill
a different number or whatever feel free
to bring an amendment to next week okay
because we're already going to be doing
a public hearing on the other amendment
to this bill that's non-
gerain and we won't be executing this
until next week okay so keep in mind
every Amendment will have to be offered
voted on and then may or may not affect
the bill oh I I understand the process I
just wanted to make sure it was okay to
do it but every member has the right to
go and pull an amendment if they feel
like it and offer it up during exec once
the Bill's open for Amendment okay thank
that and we have about a 5 minute
break minutes oh no 20 minutes sorry I
set that one 45 minutes thought it might
take longer you never
know I thought there'd be a lot of
people objecting to the Fine
[Music]
time
theil
right regular legislative account
sometimes I have to send from there
AB
heading
to
e
to The Fish and Game committee this is
the committee that uh decides laws that
might deal with hunting and fishing and
um ocean life situations here in New
Hampshire so if if there's an idea that
you all have that you think something
needs to change it would end up as a
bill coming to this committee after you
have a a legislator sponsor it for
you and if there's any questions from
the Girl Scouts we'll take a few of
[Music]
we just today um added a new weapon to
rifles representative
oulette I have a quick question for our
cookies I I I have some money I would
both are you going to share
representative
absolutely okay
and is there anybody else have anything
they want to say to the girl scouts
before we go move on to the
bill I we just encourage all of the
scouts to stay with the program I raised
four boys and they all became Eagle
Scouts and it was the best thing that
ever happened to them so please stay
[Music]
if you have the means and and the um
desire to take a photo here in the room
with us you could get here in the middle
and we'll stand up back here so we're
not blocked by you and then you could
picture hope You' all don't mind the
bill
I am opening the hearing on HB
579 and I am recognizing the prime
room really we got an extra warning
about that this year some people were
thank you representative thank you Mr
chairman and committee members I am
representative Claudine Burnham represen
representing straford District 2 I'm
introducing HB 579 requiring applicants
for a fish and game guides license to
take and and pass a standardized test
provided by the fish and game department
before receiving their
license for a person to become a
licensed H hunting or fishing guide they
must apply and take a written and oral
scenario test the applicant must pass
the written test with a 70% or better
this portion of the exam is provided by
a fishing game officer the applicant is
provided with a list of various books
and materials of which to study from
some of which do not pertain to the test
or requirements to become a guide the
oral oral part of the exam is provided
by a guide who is in The Business of
Being a guide and not a fishing game
officer this portion of the exam is
provided as an oral scenario no written
format is provided even though there may
be several answers to this oral scenario
the correct answer is determined by the
guide an applicant May score 100% on the
written exam but if they do not pass the
one or two oral scenarios the applicant
fails to receive a
license this bill will ensure that both
the written and oral exams are provided
by Fish and Game officers after learning
from my constituents that fishing game
officers are not licensed as guides nor
are they required to take the or oral
scenario portion of this examination
process I then requested amendment
number 25-
0745 which you should have in front of
you which changes section B to read the
following any required written or oral
examinations to become a guide shall be
administered only by a fishing game
officer this language just clarifies
that the guide's test is authorized and
conducted by fishing game officers
only since this licensing is the
responsibility of fishing game this is
who the testing should be administered
by after all when I want to get my
driver's license I can take an exam
provided by the Department of Motor
Vehicles not by the American Automobile
Association please consider passing HB
579 with the amendment and provide our
future guides a better standardized exam
with which they can prepare for and
receive a consistent method of testing
thank
you thank you representative uh there
are any
questions representative
wette um looking at the bill and um
under Part B that should be test should
be got uh administered by a fishing game
officer why is there no fiscal note
because it's going to take our fishing
game officers time and and uh there's a
cost to it that's a good question but
the the fishing game officers are
already administering the written exam
so why not just do the oral portion at
time representative
Harvey uh so my question pertains to um
section c um all questions questions and
answers shall be made available in a
study guide for examiners to review and
study once an application is submitted
are you suggesting that the exact
questions and answers that are going to
be on the test be in that study guide no
I'm not I'm not suggesting that but
there should be questions that pertain
to the exam when you're given a list of
20 or so books to read um and um perhaps
some of that information might be on the
exam and maybe not be on the exam it's
really difficult to study so if was
something that was more ciled to the
exam as to what they're expecting that
would be a better situation those types
of um items are available uh at in other
at other fishing game uh guides programs
so they do get some type of literature
to to assist them may I have a followup
please followup thank you um yes it it
was my understanding when we saw this
bill before that sample tests were put
online but my other question then is
um from the same section you're not are
you are you suggesting that those
questions and answers should not be
changed on a regular basis that are used
as a guide to review and study that in
other words the study guide might change
on a fairly regular basis are you
suggesting
otherwise like any test they are
typically changed because you know if
they're applying several times um so I'm
not suggesting they have to be the same
exact uh questions but it's should just
think of um long time ago when you got
your driver's license we got a book full
of different scenarios and questions we
weren't tested on all of them I think
there was maybe 40 on that but we St
there was a specific guide for that uh
should we know all of it perhaps that
would be helpful when we're driving but
um that doesn't mean all of that is on
the actual exam we're just looking for a
standardized approach so it's not one
method for one individual and a
else representa Pearson thank you it
says here in um the B
section that all uh written and oral
examinations be become a guide shall be
administered by a fishing game officer
who is also a licensed guide in New
Hampshire MH
how many fish and game officers are
licensed guides I don't believe any of
them are and that's why I have the
amendment I took that language
out oh I see I'm sorry my apologies
thank
you representative
DeVito um thank you for taking my
question have you ever been out hunting
with a guide a licensed guide here in
New Hampshire I have not I am I am here
uh representing constituents from
several uh locations that have reached
out to me uh there are a couple that are
here uh that are brave enough to be here
so um but that I've been reached out to
by email and phone calls and um there's
a lot of discussion about this bill
people that have been applying year
after year after year they'll pass that
written test fine and it comes to that
oral examination that's provided
currently by a guide who own owns a
guide
business and they typically fail which
then they fail to receive a license so
there's something that's that doesn't
balance out there we're just asking that
fish and game take the responsibility of
both portions of the
exam representative Khan thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative taking
my question representative I'm just
refreshing my memory didn't we uh
discussed this bill at the last uh
session and was it your bill Yes
actually it was and so I have taken some
con um constructive criticism and just
kind of narrow it down to really what
the issue is I think it's very simple to
make this adjustment it won't cost
fishing game additional funding um and I
think it would be a fair assessment as
to where the applicant stands thank you
represent
oulette thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question what is the
failure rate on the tests that I can't
give you because that information is not
public any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
all the chair now recognizes David
P representing himself I assume because
e
thank you sir any questions
representative Harvey had her hand up
surprise um
so
um we heard testimony from the pre
previous speakers that on the oral exams
and that maybe that could be um on
practicums that there could possibly be
two answers um to a situation H how how
do you how do you how do you deal with
that like is one writer than the other
like can you turn the mic on by the way
I just sorry uh we correct them as they
take them or at the end so we send them
out they're two sections of the test um
as a complete one section they're sent
out we correct that section if they
don't pass that section we don't make
them take the other section so they need
to leave and then take whatever section
they didn't pass again um and they're
corrected right then unlike oral boards
that for those of you that AR in in
professions that that you are subject to
oral boards
um my oral boards and the fire service
the I was sat on the other side of the
table for firefighters and it was a
question
and it said at the bottom of it 30
points period ours are actually divided
up um so for
instance I can give away one I can give
away one question so if if you're
scenario your your person fell down and
is not breathing and is not beating and
is not
moving and you don't do CPR you will not
be a guide period that's the end of the
day so if that is a cause for somebody
to be concerned
then we're then I I have been wrong for
a long time um but there are points so
for instance if you don't put on if I
didn't as an EMT put on my gloves I
failed no matter how well I did CPR
that's not necessarily the case here
because we're in the woods we know
people don't adhere to those same
standards that we adhere to so
although they should because we
shouldn't share bodily fluids but that's
another that's another thing um so those
are those are issues that are graded and
to say that they are not that they are
individual that we give an test to an
individual and a different test to the
next individual is not
correct I not a position to divulge the
contents of the test but I can tell you
that those tests are written they are
formulated and they are used there are
multiple tests so there may be different
tests given that day but they are not
ones Dave P didn't sit down and make up
a test for candidate a and then with
different answers and candidate B for
different answers that does not
happen followup followup so um and I
understand you said you know
electricians license there's going to be
electricians on the board and
firefighters and so forth so the
amendment would um take that restriction
away so they would be Fish and Game
officers but they would not be Fish and
Game officers that are also guides um do
you feel in your experience that fish
and game
officers since they're not licensed as
guides are the one are CA capable of
judging the the oral part of the the
test are they do they have
you know the the knowledge that they
would need in order to make a um
intelligent
decision I think they
do
um I would say
that as a guide I come to it a little
bit differently than than an officer
might and I come to it as a uh as a
service um if you'll indulge me for a
moment I'll give you an example of a by
all means so if you in one of the tests
that we now don't use we won't use
anymore uh the individual was asked to
navigate over Frozen ice um in the dark
we expect certain answers the fact that
I'm going to take out my compass and sit
on an ATV and drive and expect to get a
correct answer will never ever pass the
test for a whole bunch of
reasons um however we
expect the them to give us some which
you learned in Hunter by the way none of
this you learned this technique in
Hunter education in that 45
minutes um however we had one individual
that came and said well I
would take a bearing on the Stars I know
where the North Star is I know where and
went right through the process and the
officer and I look at we looked each
other went great answer we didn't think
of that but we didn't tell them it was
cloudy so great answer so that's an
example of it's not a you don't do it
I'm going to say Dave's way or the or
the way Christian game wants that we
don't accept the answer but the answer
outcome did that
help yes thank
or that is
up using a different test on each person
during the O exam I would imagine not
necessarily sir um the it it's a
different test if you're fishing or
hunting um and other than that I would
say unless an individual came in for a
second time so fishing game notes that
and they won't be given that same test
again so we could use different tests
but typically over the day if they're
all brand new people we use the same
followup follow up so
um who decides whether the you said
there's two or three who decides always
two always two um does it take two to
fail them or one to fail them or I'm
sorry when he answers the question who
decides you're both one says he's good
one says he's
bad uh the way it's done is the
currently is the re
so you get five points
for doing this activity you get five
points for doing this activity the total
is 20 points so I might check off two of
the four and the person I'm with cat
checks off three of the four and when we
send them out of the room go well I've
only got I only heard two of those
answers well I heard I heard this person
say d d d so in the end our grading is
very very close if not exactly the same
so I think so it would take two of us to
fail I guess it takes two to pass or
fail you know but I I have never been
and again I've been involved in this
institution and I have not been in a
circumstance where we
had a situation that we
disagreed
adamant
questions seeing none thank you for your
time
today chair now
recognizes
Ken Deon
New Hampshire guides
gentlemen um so on behalf of the guides
Association we are opposed to uh this
bill um I'd like to say that um so I I
was also a licensed guide in Alaska and
I remember telling the guys out there
you know New Hampshire is a small state
when when you're in Alaska you're you
know it's it's big and vast and people
think this is the real deal well you
come to New Hampshire and you get in the
middle of our mountain range or whether
you're in the middle of the Alaska range
it's all relevant it's it's it's
relevant you're in the wilderness and so
training is
essential now we have uh the New
Hampshire Outdoor Learning Center that
does a guide school program on many of
the guys that take the test have have
gone through that program they do pretty
well does everybody pass a first time of
course not
most people do most people do come back
and retest and and do
pass is that you know the the gentleman
sitting on the board on doing the oral
exam i' I've never been there myself um
but they are not there to fail anybody
they just want the individuals to be the
very best they can be they take great
pride in in the test they take great
pride in the state of New Hampshire they
just want these guys to be guys and gals
to be the best they can be so it's it's
like like no other exam I mean study
study guys you know and as far as the
oral exam is concerned like Mr P just
stated there's there's two or three
people there they're they're working on
a grading system they're comparing so
it's it it's not set up to make somebody
fail so I just like the board to
understand that we really take great
pride in this and we take great pride in
the guides that we have here in the
state of New Hampshire
questions thank you for your time thank
much chair now recognizes Captain
Michael Eastman from the New Hampshire
department good afternoon chair Spain
and committee thank you for hearing me
today um so I am here at the beest of
the uh Fishing Game Commission and they
are opposed uh to this bill for several
reasons um one of which is that
um the uh section B um of this uh of
this bill speaks about a uh conservation
officer uh who is a licensed guide um
being part of this oral board or the
only people on this oral board um so
there is already there will always will
be a conservation officer on this board
um they're not a licensed guide we do
not have any conser a officers at our
license guide we had one um and he is in
a sense retired um understand we don't
encourage our officers to be guides um
when they become conservation officers
because really it is a conflict of
interest um they you know to have a
conservation officer driving around all
week and you know it's moose Seasons
coming up and they're going to guide for
somebody and they see a bull um in an
area that's a bit of a uh you know and
then they take that person who's paying
them that's a that's a conflict of
interest um so uh you know really that's
uh that's one section um and also after
the fact um you know if we were to you
know we we try to have the same officers
on there but certainly days off conflict
and and vacations and such so having
other officers be able to go in and do
that essentially that same uh role um
but you know we uh at full contingent
have 48 officers and we would have to to
certify All 48 officers for being guides
and um as representative olette pointed
out this really that would be a
financial burden um on the department as
well
because when you ask you know an
employee to do something in and above
what they you know are are doing you
have to pay for that and right now
there's a lawsuit going on in the state
for inband uh where if you hold a
certification so if I hold a
certification because I'm on the dive
team I get to have I get to have a
higher pay grade because I have hold
that certification so now for you are
also paying for them to be certified but
also paying for that increase in their
pay because you have now certified them
so um and any anything else that we do
uh you know though it's it's uh
Wilderness first responder a dive
training whatever the case may be the
department takes on that that uh that
cost so really
that's a burden um on on the department
um the other portion of the bill C I'll
speak to is that um and from the
previous years that the similar bill has
been uh introduced um there was some uh
actually this committee suggested that
we give examples of what a test looks
like and now um an older test is
actually online um so that it can be
reviewed and um you know anyone that's
applying can actually go on there and
have have kind of an idea of what that
looks like now asking us to to take you
know tests that we're currently giving
and putting on there with the answers I
I think that's unreasonable as is
previously testified there are guide
schools there's one in this state
there's one in Maine um and you know
that is certainly another Avenue as well
as the other you know avenues for or the
suggestions that we give for um being
able to to review before they take that
test so really this would be a burden um
you know we have folks that come in and
pass this test all the time um certainly
there are folks that come in and don't
pass and some of them don't pass every
time that they kind of uh come in and
and take the test so um but um you know
and and and as far as if the question is
what you know what's the percentage um
sometimes we have people that come in we
have five people maybe one of those pass
maybe the next time around all five of
them pass it's really uh hit or miss but
certainly it's a passable test and uh we
do make every um every reasonable um um
effort to make to make sure that they do
pass
so representative
Khan thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question uh private
sponsor U um stated that at the last um
session the last term when we discussed
this bill or similar Bill there was some
issues and she took care of those issues
you know in this bill what is the what
what is the problem you know why we
cannot go ahead with this point how how
bill that's a great question I I don't
know what the right answer is um like I
said the the process we already have is
not unlike other states around us I know
Maine has a similar process um where
they have a written test and an oral
board um so and I don't know what you
know issues they have over there but
really um like I said this is a it's a
professional test we don't make it easy
for a reason we don't want people to to
take money and and take people out into
the onto the waters and into the woods
and then um you know I can think of one
instance before we had a a really you
know uh stringent test like this where a
guy did take a 70 and an 80y old client
out into the woods for a moose hunt and
then said oh I have some personal issues
and left them there um so you know we
certainly can't have people uh doing
that and that's why the stress that's
why this test is as stringent and we
have folks from The Guiding community
that are part of it follow follow up
follow up uh so um how many guys we give
license a year
or uh uh you know in a in a just say a
year unfortunately I don't have that
answer for you I can certainly get it
and forward it to uh the committee one
more
followup follow
up thank you Mr chairman um I am this is
just like a comment I'm not very happy
that uh your two member who take the
test you know should be three or five
you know it's it's you know I didn't
know that before just I want to express
my
um thank
you representative
Harvey um okay so I I'm getting more and
more confused um usually when I read a
bill I can see oh that's so different
from you know what's happening but I'm
having trouble seeing the difference
with this so section A doesn't change
except for the pronoun um section B simp
L says that the test would be
administered by a fishing game officer
not a licensed guide
correct the with with the amendment with
the
amendment I apologize I don't believe I
have the amendment I believe I have the
introduced uh Bill okay follow up follow
up okay and and section c I'm trying to
figure out why that's necessary because
you already
put tests online both the written test
and the oral test
um for people to look at as as possible
examples I understand that that's going
to change periodically you're not going
to give that exact test to a person
you're going to change it but you
already do that so I'm I'm just trying
to figure out why C is necessary I
guess certainly I would say that c is
not necessary we we are already
providing that provide periodicals that
they can review and we would you know
certainly ask them that they are having
issues with that um that they would you
know follow up with the schools that are
out there I will also say that uh there
is a bill in the Senate right now um
that is a uh it's an apprentice guides
bill um which also you know and that's
actually did not come from fish and game
came from the guides Association uh
which is actually which would help on
the circumstance that somebody did have
a issue with taking the test they could
become an apprentice and you know a a
mentor guide could help them um to you
know pass that test and to become better
knowledgeable to do so thank you
representative
DeVito thank you Captain for taking my
question um regarding the 48 officers
that you guys have out in the field is
it correct that you are down six right
now so you are currently um
currently don't have enough field
officers so to pull someone away it
would be even more strenuous on you
guys that is correct um currently we're
about 133% down as far as vacancies so
that is about five or six and 21% down
uh when you in when you add the injuries
that we have or folks that are out of
the field due to injuries so um yes now
certainly the amendment um speaks to
only fishing game officers but once
again
if you have five fishing game officers
you're now taking them out of the fields
um to administer this test
so representative love it thank you Mr
chair um how many guides are there today
state once again I'm not sure of that
answer I I don't know the the total
number of guides or how many licenses we
sell for it um certainly I know of some
guides that because you you don't have
to be a guide um necessarily but if you
if you purchase your license or if you
don't purchase a license for up to five
years you can then purchase another one
so that you don't have to continue to
take the test so there are some folks
out there that are just retaining their
license but not actual guides I don't
have the exact number I apologize
do this is from your
100% sure this is accurate but I could
certainly confirm when I get back but 15
fishing any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
time today thank
you about that
okay um yeah so uh I guess I wanted to
start out with just saying maybe a
little bit
um I don't know if you guys had the
information that um we have to get
certified for first aid I didn't know if
you were aware of that so we have to go
to classes for surf uh first aid in
CPR we have to get a uh commercial boers
licensed from Marine Patrol to be able
to operate the boat um you know be
licensed through for commercial to be
able to take people out
fishing and um I just wanted to say that
I am I am for this
bill I think that it's just what am I
trying to say here I want to stay stay
short
um I'm losing my train of thought I'm
not a good speaker um yeah so we're not
looking for it to be any
easier I think that's the that's the uh
I keep hearing that about making tests
easier or anything I I don't think we
need to make them any easier um
Massachusetts tells me come on down be a
guide I don't agree with that I think
you really should have a licensing thing
um so I guess I'll just leave uh you
um your uh the new director comes from
Washington State they have a nice setup
there if you want to go on their website
and see how they do guidelin
anding they go through and have to have
you uh all those certifications that I
just talked about and you have to have
insurance and um there is no testing but
you have to have insurance and
everything
else as far as the testing again I just
want to repeat that we're not looking
for it to get any easier I just feel
like the fishing game offices are the
best of the
best they're the best in Search and
Rescue
their best in all rules and laws to do
with fishing game and to do with
anything of you know being a Woodsman or
whatever they're the best of the best so
I I don't see why it has to be go to an
outside agency a outside entity the god
Association to do the oral testing
they're already taking
offices off for the day to do the paper
test I don't see it a big jump to take
them off for a day once a not even once
a month it's only uh what is it twice a
year I think the testing is twice a year
it's nothing to take them off for H five
hours to do not even 5 hours who knows
for the oral exam it's you're not you're
not putting a burden on those officers
at all I don't see it at at twice a year
and
um that's about it that's all I want to
say thanks for your time thank
you I guess no
questions chair recognizes
representative
Patza thank you Mr chair uh for the
record my name is representative Kelly
Penza straford District 19 Rochester WS
1 2 3 4 and six um I just came out in in
support of this bill I came out in
support of a similar bill
um last year
and in anything that we do with any
testing and all of that we expect this
from you know if you're if you're you
know I'm a college graduate if you go to
college if you're in high school middle
school you don't give
someone basically say okay we're going
to have a test on Friday um make sure
you learn the materials but we're not
going to provide you um with any of
those materials that tell you where you
can find the answers it's it's pure
insanity and that's what it is right now
giving giving someone that's going to be
taking a test to and they want to become
a guide or whatever or making it harder
for them you can't just give a a list of
you know 20 books or periodicals and say
okay read through all these and here you
go there should be a study guide I'm not
giving the answers because we don't do
that but on every single test that
people are taking from standardized
tests to the bar association to the SATs
to the PSATs there's all there's all
samples of what the questions could be
and you basically are giving you
materials where you can find answers to
those questions so I think we are
setting the bar ridiculously high for
one thing um and I just and I think the
outside entity piece is important as
well that we remove that and keep within
fish and game um you know there's some
people here that I see that I recognize
that have you know tried um feverishly
to get a license and they've come up
with this and that's you know and they
came to of course their representatives
to help fix this problem it shouldn't be
must to ask we want everyone involved in
working with um our environment um it's
a good of course Revenue generator for
our state uh travel and tourism all of
that um so we're not we're not going to
put unqualified people out but I did
look last year at other at other states
and we
are really Beyond ridiculously stringent
in this and and a control factor and I'm
hoping that um you all see the amendment
which is good and that we can make these
changes which are very minimal um to
thank you any
questions representative Harvey um thank
you Mr chair I'm trying to figure out
how to word this as a question um so
um I I hear you say that
um we're not providing the
materials that um are needed in order
for candidates to learn what they need
to learn to be on the test and that's
not what's done in schools I sort of
remember a curriculum um review but
someone you even said that they're given
you know a up to 20 books that there's a
guide school and so forth so I feel are
you contradicting yourself a little bit
I'm it's not a nice way for me to ask
that question no I'm not contradicting
myself maybe I wasn't clear so if you if
you're giving like books that aren't
specifically what the test is like
random books that you should learn or
read just to learn about it that could
have multitudes of different subjects
which you have no idea where the test is
going to be focused on you've got to
give someone um without giving them the
answers hey this is what you're going to
this is what we're going to be focused
on learn these subject areas you can't
find any of that you also can't even
find a phone number um about this to get
get more information on the fishing game
scarce any other questions
you when you take a test to get your
boers driver's license you go online and
you can't go to chapter 2 until you
finish you know you complete chapter one
you just keep testing on until you
finish
and then you're able to take the
test it's one of the things that I think
about when we're sort of talking about
the number of books and who's
administering the test and and I just I
mean I know that's probably a certainly
an FN component to this question but I'm
just I guess the question is would that
be a standard that you would like to
see to a test to take your guide's
license where you have to just
is it does that exist in another state I
know that there's practice tests that
exist in other states um so you know
what the the content is going to be
which not giving you the answers but the
practice test is great I mean I've done
tons of those um you know so you can
know where you're at the beautiful part
about like a practice test if if you're
failing it um or a study guide which has
a practice test attached to it is let's
say you fail it it then tells you you
need to go back to this this periodical
and this periodical and this periodical
this book or this chapter in review
because that's where the answers are so
we're not doing any of
that so yes I think and I don't think it
would cost a lot of money to do this I
think it's they are I think it's just a
little bit about being better organized
and having more information out there
for the public there not really much
information or where to go for this
twice a year it's very controlled um
this bill's not asking for that to be
opened up it's not asking for there to
be more time more testing or any of that
that would put a burden on fishing game
this shouldn't put a burden on it let's
keep the expertise inside let's keep it
with the fishing game officers um let's
button it up let's make it easier in the
sense for people to be able to study and
know what they're going to be tested on
and to Hope that they can um and get and
get where they want to want to be for
whether it's fishing or hunting or
whatever it may be thank you any other
questions there is a
pH seeing none thank you for your
time is there anyone who wants to speak
hello I'm Glenn Burnham and um my
concern about the oral exam is the um
fact is that they don't give you the
answers to these questions so they go
through this scenario with you and then
they tell you you you passed fail well
wouldn't it
be good for the people taking it to at
least give them a ver
explanation of what happened what didn't
you know what was wrong with that
scenario what was wrong with that answer
they not the right it down but I also
think that being a
guide it would only be in their best
benefit knowing the answers that their
spouses their friends anybody around
them would be familiar with the
answers whereas the person that doesn't
have a friend as a guide is you know out
out the do he doesn't know where to ask
these questions if you're not giving him
an answer to your question how can you
solve it go back to the 20 books again I
think a little more clarity um and then
that way there we don't feel like
there's a conflict of interest with a
guide versus offish game officer that's
all thank you anybody have any
questions seeing none thank you so much
for your time today thank you
sir seeing no more cards is there
anybody else in the audience who has yet
to speak and would like
to seeing none I now close the hearing
579 members of the committee the only
Bill that we could possibly EXA today
because of the need to wait for the
amendment hearing is 579 does anybody
feel prepared to exact that today or do
you want to wait I would prefer to
wait having one member decide that they
would prefer to wait I I would like to
vote you'd like to vote today I would
yes
okay all right so we've got two that
would like to go ahead and exec and one
that wanted to wait I'd like to get a
consensus of the committee so we can
actually get a uh uh decent handle on
whether we should or not so I'll do by a
raise of hands point of order just if
we're going to exec this bill can we
have discussion about it we will during
the exec first um rather than just
calling for the vote yeah it would be a
discussion during exact session
okay um so um how many of you would like
today and how many would like to
wait looks like uh exec today wins so I
579 and I will take a motion from
representative
Smith thank you Mr chair I make a motion
579 and I have a second from Sarah I
all right it's open for
discussion representative Harvey would
you like to lead off our
discussion
um well no because my thoughts aren't
organized go to somebody else and I'll I
will raise my hand though so anybody
else have an opinion on the bill they'd
like to to put forward to everybody
representative tutor yeah I'm just I'm
not sure how I feel about the bill now
uh I'm struggling
with uh how standardized the test that
one guy gets to the next I have a really
hard time believing that you know three
people listening to answers and nobody
ever
disagrees um so and that they get no
feedback on how they did or didn't do um
I mean every time I took a test in
college I I got the test back and it
usually had Mar on I could go to the
professor and say hey you know what did
I mess up here and he'd sit down and
tell me no Paul you know it's the the
physics isn't right here you got to you
got to you know approach it from a
different direction um just that you
know they walk in take an oil test and
and and they get no
feedback and I think there should be a
study guide for any test you take
doesn't necessarily have the answers but
it should have an outline of the
material and then you we can have
practice test or not have practice test
I don't need to practice test if I have
a guide that tells me you know these are
these are the topics and the areas that
I need to concentrate that are in 50
pages of the 500 you gave me um so yeah
I'm really struggling with how I'm going
this representative
DeVito so my husband is a license guide
not just in New Hampshire but also Maine
which is supposedly the hardest guide
license to obtain in the United States
um he failed it three times but um I sat
there and watched him study um in
between both of his jobs to ensure that
he did pass it's not easy and that's on
purpose because you are um you're in
charge of other people's lives you're
responsible for them whenever you're out
there guiding them and that guides take
that seriously um if this was a test
that was easy I don't know that I would
want to go with a guide and I wouldn't
even respect it um right now it is
highly respected um in the format that
it is and my husband would come home
whenever he failed and be so upset um on
the oral he did complain about that um
but the guys that were sitting there
talking to him and testing him they did
walk him through what he messed up on
and he went back and studied he also
there is a guide service that you can be
a part of and he studied with that um
it's a it's a class and he took that
class um and so those things are out
there for people that want them um he
did have several books that he read and
um he hunts he's been an avid Hunter um
the last probably 20 years and um he was
able to to finally get his guide license
so it's not impossible um but those the
the standard is very high and there's a
reason for that so that is why I'm not
in favor of um doing just a standardized
test or um changing this also I think it
needs to be known if you haven't taken a
guide test there are a million
possibilities of things that could
happen on the water and in the woods
there's not 10 things that they can put
on a piece of paper and say these are
the 10 things that you're going to run
into whenever you're out guiding someone
and so these are the things you need to
study that's why there's a lot of books
because there's all sorts of
probabilities that could happen um
whenever they are testing you out of the
million they may test you or talk to you
about
10 um so there's nothing that they can't
put on on a piece of paper um all of
those and say hey here's here's the 10
things that we're going to test you over
they're going to change that um I know
that my husband whenever he went in the
three times they were different test all
three
times
so representative Harvey thank you Mr
chair I've been
waiting you're very patient um so I
agree I'm I'm I'm leaning more and more
towards the itl thank you for your
comments
although I don't think that it was ever
the intent of this bill or any of the
speakers to do away with the oral part
of the
test the it was just a a way to figure
out a way that even the oral part could
become more standardized um I liked the
idea that on the oral part of the test
it's not pass fail you get so many
points um there there is a guide school
so you can take advantage of that
I I Heard lots of thing complaints about
well you gave me 20 books to read um but
um I don't know I got a lot of books to
read when I was in college and I didn't
think any of them applied to the test
um right and I do hear you say that you
know it it's it's hard to uh predict
what things you're going
to run up against out in the wilderness
it could be anything so maybe 20 books
is not even enough I do like the idea of
an apprenticeship but we'll see that in
a senate senate bill yeah when that
comes um um uh so I I'm wondering you
know there's not a lot of difference
between what's going on now and what
what we what this Bill is saying except
that the test would be given by a
fishing game officer instead of a guide
because there there are tests online and
the reason those tests are online is
because last year when we saw this bill
we made that suggestion that we're going
to leave things the way they are but
could you please put up some sort of
online testing I am I I'm correct in
that and I was actually going to verify
that today but he made a comment about
that before I even got to ask him so so
my question I guess is um if we itl this
bill can we make a um suggestion from
the committee I I get the fishing can do
what they want but can we make a
suggestion from the committee that they
go over the the answers that people have
gotten wrong in the oral section I do
think that's fair I you know whenever
I've missed something somebody's told me
believe me they love to tell me what I
do wrong so um I'm wondering if if we do
itl this if we could just as a as a
committee make the recommendation that
in future oral tests the tester goes
over with the teste
why your answer was not acceptable
answer would is that a weird idea not at
all thank you very much representative
Khan thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman
I'm a very big supporter of the
commission and the
department um always uh but in this case
um I am very concerned about just two
member of
the uh interview or uh the commission
that who took take care of the
licensing uh the other thing is uh the
last year when we to took the testimony
it was many many people you know
testified in front of us uh uh the
commission had U opportunity and chance
to fix some of those concern this year
the problem didn't go way uh the prime
sponsor is so so passionate about it
because her district and the citizens of
our state that she brought out a better
bill I am confused now that what how I'm
going to
vote thank you representative
Fox couple quick things first of all uh
to your point about a million things
that mother nature could theoretically
throw at you um 20 books probably isn't
enough um and and no two tests are going
to be the same um I'm coming at it from
a standpoint of I have a 15-year-old
daughter who all of her friends are in
the process of trying to get the
driver's licenses and everybody who
doesn't pass has a complaint or says
this TMV is harder you got that guy he
was harder she's easy so there's always
going to be that sort of degree of
difference among tests situations all of
that and there's no amount of correction
that we can do that that really would
mitigate that outside of standardizing
it which I think defeats the purpose of
M and and the point of the fact that
when you're in nature anything can
happen and you have to be prepared for
all of it because you have the lives of
the people that you're with uh that
you're responsible
for I can empathize with you my middle
child failed his driving test three
times to be clear just in case she or
her friends happen to be super bored and
watching this she has not failed it
yet my suggestion to my ex-wife was to
ask him to please remember the route he
drives and go out there every day after
school and let him drive it because the
more comfortable with that route he
becomes the less likely he is to get
nervous and make a mistake because I
know my son and I knew that every time
he made a mistake it was because he was
so nervous about not failing that he put
himself into a corner where he would
fail and he finally passed it because he
drove that same route so often that he
was very comfortable doing
it uh representative love it I I
appreciate this conversation this is
what I was looking
for I I would be in I I think the other
thing that I think is important it
sounds like several of the issues
haven't been addressed over the past 12
months or
longer what we've also heard that
fishing game doesn't have the people
power the manpower to to take this
responsibility
on and I think for that reason alone itl
is the way to
go thank you representative
wette just one quick uh
statement the um having the fishing game
officers uh do the oral part of the test
is it doesn't quite sit right with me
because the guys are the experts in
guiding not the fishing game officers
they have know their job and they know
but what the guides know the guiding
business and I think that they have to
representative tutor yeah I mean for me
it comes back to feedback I mean you
said your husband failed three times but
you got feedback each time he failed so
that he had some idea of where he was
deficient um and perhaps the guys can
chime back in and that they do give
feedback I haven't heard that I believe
that they do not um and that's really
the big thing for me if if they were
receiving some sort of feedback I don't
want to make a test easy and lose 10
people in the woods next year here but I
think it's just fair to give people
feedback on where they're deficient and
where they failed let's clear up the
question of feedback and ask the person
feedback thank you um so when we started
this process we actually did give
feedback um detailed feedback to the uh
applicant the problem is these tests are
between they're about a year in
development
it takes us about a year to come up with
a with the the oral board and it's to
complete a test run it through all of
those verification uh stages so as soon
as we give the answers the test is blown
up so if if for instance I said you know
you you have a scenario where
uh trying not to give up a test
um you got a hook in the ear we haven't
used this one for a long time and I give
you the correct answer to that as soon
as I tell you how to deal with it I can
never use that scenario again so the
test and and the way the system works is
the guide School actually it's it would
be more uh suitably called a test
preparation school um as well as a guide
school so they are really anxious to get
folks through the process so as soon as
we gave them those answ answers we found
that the next person that came
back actually challenged me because I
didn't have the right person go get the
wood the next time so it it is
unfortunately we don't give the answers
um and in some cases it's very difficult
um I will I will say to
clarify a little bit with this 20
there's 20
books um and there's probably more um um
because one of them is a group of
pamphlets that's that's probably 30 I
think count of 37 of pamphlets um
however there is a sample test online uh
two sample tests one of each of the two
uh types of tests it's given
and I I don't know what else um we tried
to give the we tried to give feedback
detailed feedback to get folks ready to
pass but it turned out that we had to
make up new tests every single 6
months one second did that get worse
with the
Internet
it's I don't want to get into the
business of folks that are involved in
this process but it's more immediate
than that okay I we have given a test
at8 used the same test at three and
miraculously the people who took it to
three passed wow so representative tutor
then Harvey yeah and thank you Mr chair
thank you again for taking my question
I'm not looking for you to give the
answer but I'm looking for you to point
out the area that he is deficient in was
well you
failed crawling on the ice not that you
failed you didn't look at the stars or
you didn't have a rope behind you you
didn't use a kayak to go out there um
okay you took your four-wheeler you just
this is the area that you failed in so
did he go back and review that
particular book or section of material
and know that okay I got got to
strengthen myself here so that's all I'm
looking for I'm not looking for you to
say you know you failed one plus one and
you put three in the answer is two
right representative Harvey and and I
since we're discussing I don't think
this has to be a question but um I agree
there's way ways to give feedback
without giving the answer for instance
you can make the recommendation well for
perhaps you need to go back and read
book number two one more time and that's
even less of um feedback than what what
you're suggesting but and and it as to
this situation of well you you give them
feedback at nine o'clock and then the
person that takes the test at 3:00
passes it then you can simply say if you
want to know you know what what you need
to study more of come back at 5 and
we'll go over your test with you the as
an educator for 43 years there's ways to
get around everything that you're saying
and still be fair to the person who is
taking the test and give them feedback
so that they can take the test three
times or whatever representative DeVito
I wanted to clarify my husband whenever
he said that he did receive feedback um
one of the things that he did not pass
on was the compass portion um and that
was not one of his strong suits he knew
that going into it um and that is the
part that he failed so he knew um so I
believe from my understanding with my
husband if you fail a certain part the
test is over so at that time you know
that's you know you may you may suck at
other things on the test as well but you
know that for sure you got to go back
and study the compass so um that's what
I me I just wanted to clarify they did
not give him the answers they didn't
write anything down they didn't give him
anything specific it was just that
portion any other discussion
items representative
Jacobs thank you you um I I feel like
what I'm really hearing is that there's
a huge there there's a big difference
between a guide and a fishing game
conservation officer um so I'm wondering
how different is the training of a fish
and game officer from a guide um I would
really expect that they'd really have
some of the same skill sets especially
if ficient game officers um are
performing rescues you know isn't that
I'm just wondering what the differences
are because to me it seems like there
should be a significant amount of
overlap thank you Colonel Jordan would
you like to step up and tell us what
kind of training so you actually I make
them take the guys test so that's how we
tested this whole procedure is I I once
we created these exams I put them out to
the field force and had them take them
and scored them so we could make sure
that we weren't producing something that
wasn't going to be able to be passed
they are capable of being guides I
encourage them not to be because it's
very easy to have a conflict there uh if
they're a paid guide on Saturday when
they're on a day off and Friday they're
working because no matter how honest
they are they're going to be looking for
places while they're working that they
can guide in for the weekend so we don't
allow them to be guides what where I
would have a problem I don't have the
staff to put five officers commit them
to this guiding test so um number one
and number two uh I think it's important
to have a and I think representative
Tudor mentioned I think it's important
to have a member of the guides
Association involved because they're the
ones actually doing it much like a fire
department promotional board where you
put firemen on the on that board I think
that's an important piece to that so and
I I'm I wasn't here and I apologize I
was downstairs beating the table on
another very important bill to me but um
you I want to make sure you understand
there's a ton of people that pass this
so we have some great successes with us
I realize not everybody does there are
people that struggle with it but don't
lose sight of the fact there's a ton of
people that have passed this and it's
worked very well so and we've taken
steps the guides Association put on that
have has got that bill coming towards
you for a guides apprentice license
which I think will help it'll get guides
out that want to take this test ahead of
time to work with a guide much like our
hunter Apprentice which has worked
really well uh we put the test online
based on our testimony from the last
time this bill came uh David helped us
and we did that that's up online so
people can see a good example there are
instate resources they're not cheap
they're schools that people can attend
I'm really thrilled to hear that the
clerk's husband failed that's really
that kind of was important to know
before I got here I I apologize to him
and I hope he comes back and you're
absolutely
right yeah and you're absolutely and
that's what happens a lot of time you're
absolutely right when they fail a
section the test stops and so you they
leave I am convinced they leave with an
idea of what went wrong they may not
know the exact question but they know
what area they're weak in um and I've
never taking a test frankly when I left
that I didn't know what I needed to Bone
up on you know that going in so the
thing I like about it think guides
Association likes about is it brought
guides to a level that New Hampshire had
never seen before so before we had a
standardized test single written test it
was everybody knew what it was we'd used
it for years you come in sit down take
the test and went out the door as a
guide it was frightening so now we make
sure they can navigate they have some
first aid skills they can operate on the
water it's just more responsible I think
and one last thing I want to leave you
with at 34 years of doing this I've
never done a Rescue Mission in search of
a guide or his client in the state of
New Hampshire I think that's commendable
um that tells me that our guides are
pretty good at what they do we've never
had one and I think this will only this
program will only help to enhance that
for future Generations so thank you
thank you representative
Durkin well first of all I raised my
hand because I was feeling left out
because everybody's been speaking I had
a chance yet so so here's my chance um I
spent enough time in the woods and on
the water to know that you don't become
a guide by reading a couple books that
you need to put your time in in the
woods or on the water yes sir and I
think that um I will be voting against
this because who better to administer a
test
than somebody who has spent the time put
the time in um and is an expert at what
they do right um therefore I I'm going
to vote
itl thank you any other uh comments for
the exact session or uh should we move
on to the vote all right the clerk will
role sorry about that chairman Spain yes
yes Vice chairman or vice chairman
ulette yes representative con yes
representative Smith yes representative
tutor yes representative Murphy yes
representative Durkin uh
yes clerk votes yes representative
Harvey yes representative Fox yes
representative lit yes representative
Jacobs yes representative oor yes
representative Pearson yes
any objection to
consent this closes the exec session on
uh HP
579 and it ends our
day oddly enough right at 4 when I
[Music]